AFTERNOON AND I WILL BE MAKING
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE ARE SENT
TO WORK DURING THE PAST MAKE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH
THIS PROCESS PRECIADO PATIENTS
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN
PROPOSED TURNING AND TURNING
FOR THE FIRST. TIME HELLO ME
COVER THE TECHNICAL SIDE BEING
THE DAY. THE COULD NINETEEN
EMERGED. PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
BUT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
LOCAL ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS. STILL I JUST
PROCESS WORKED WHAT HEARING IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY THE PUBLIC AND ARE
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL JUSTICE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. USING A
CONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL WEST WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WILL BE PLAYED ON THE SCREEN
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIXTY THREE SIXTY FOUR. AN
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHTY FORTY
FIVE THREE FIFTY SIX. I DON'T
REPEAT BARBATOS ONE MORE TIME.
HIS PIN NUMBER IS.
1-844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHTY FORTY FIVE
THREE FIFTY SIX. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT THE MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE KNOW THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU CAN USE THE
DEVICE WATCHING HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. PLIABLE I
MEAN CORN DURING THE AT. IN ANY
IN THE WHO ARE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE. TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES
FOR. US INTO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO PLEASE BE PATIENT SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. BOB HALF
OF OUR SCENOGRAPHER I AM ALL.
INCLUDING MY COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. K. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. REMINDER MEMBERS SHOW
NEED TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY
TIME WE VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTH YEAR
EIGHTH HERE MINING YEAR
LEARNING HERE ROTH YOU'RE RIGHT
HERE WILK. PRESIDENT WILL
PRESENT. FOR ALL RIGHT- FOR
MEMBERS ARE HERE SO QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED SO LET'S BEGIN
OUR GENDER AGENDA. FIRST UP WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
IN OUR FIRST A POINT IS MISTER
GUSTAVO VELASQUEZ DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. WELCOME
DIRECTOR VELASQUEZ IS THERE
ANYONE WITH YOU THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR BECAUSE
WE WELCOME THOSE INTRODUCTIONS
AND THEN GO AHEAD WITH ANY
OPENING COMMENTS YOU LIKE TO
MAKE AND AFTER THAT WE'LL MOVE
TO QUESTIONS GLORIA HERE'S-
THANK YOU- VICE CHAIR WILK
MEMBERS OF THE COME. IT IS A
GREAT HONOR TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING MY FAMILY MY WIFE
FAMILY AND MY TWO BOYS
SEBASTIAAN AND HAVE YEAR FOR
THEIR LOVE AND SUPPORT. ALSO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
GOVERNOR AND SECRETARY CUSTOMER
METERS FOR THEIR CONFIDENCE AND
SUPPORT. I HAVE DEVOTED MY
CAREER TO SERVE IN THE PUBLIC
IN NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS IN
LOCAL AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS.
MY FIRST JOB WAS WELCOMING
HUNDREDS OF POOR AND
PREDOMINANTLY MINORITY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
SEEKING THE MOST BASIC
ASSISTANCE FROM OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY NET LOOKING FOR A
HOUSING VOUCHER. OF FOOD STAMP
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR A BETTER
JOB. THAT EXPERIENCE SHAPED IN
MANY WAYS MY BEER AND MY
PHILOSOPHY AROUND HOUSING
POLICY. I BELIEVE HOME IS AN
ANCHOR IN PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT
CAN HIDE THEIR FACILITY BASED
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY OR IMPEDE IT.
MY MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT USED TO SUPPORT
EVERY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TO
CREATE HOMES. THAT ARE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE AND THROUGH THE
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION AND
PROTECTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUILD MORE INCLUSIVE
AND ECONOMICALLY PROSPEROUS
COMMUNITIES. UNDER MY
LEADERSHIP I COMMIT TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU. SENATORS AND
ALL OTHERS IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO. SURE HCV IS THE GOAL TO
RELIABLE PARTNER FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS. YOUR VISION.
SENATOR I AM NEW TO COME BUT I
AM NOT NEW TO CHALLENGES WE
COME FROM I'VE BEEN STUDENT IN
A DECISION MAKER AROUND THOSE
CHALLENGES AT THE LOCAL AND
NATIONAL LEVEL FOR MANY YEARS.
I ALMOST THREE MONTHS SINCE I
PLEASURE TO START HERE AT EIGHT
CV. AND MY LEADERSHIP STYLE HAS
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
REACHING OUT TO ALL OF OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS. LISTEN LEARN
FROM THEM AND WORK. WITH THEM
TO SOLVE THE DIFFICULT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY PROBLEMS WE FACE
WHICH AS YOU MIGHT HAVE ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED BY. ONLY A
VERY. IN GREW OF AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING THEM. WITH
GUIDANCE AND LEADERSHIP. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
NOMINATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO THESE AND MANY MORE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE FUTURE.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT AND TURNED TO MY
COLLEAGUES WILL START WITH
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LET ME START
BY. OFFERING MY CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU MISTER VELASQUEZ WE HAD
A GOOD CONVERSATION THE OTHER
DAY I'M SO IMPRESSED WITH YEAR
HISTORY OF SERVICE BOTH AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. NOW WITH YOUR
MEANT HEARING CALIFORNIANS
CERTAINLY IT'S A LARGE MISSION
I THINK YOU BRING UP. A VISION
THAT IS THE EXACT RIGHT VISION
FOR OUR TIME WE TALKED SOME
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN BOTH INTERNALLY WITHIN
YOUR DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO HOW IT
MIGHT AFFECT SOME OF THE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES. IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION AND FUNDING THAT
WE'VE PASSED TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME. AREAS AREAS IN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY WAS IT WAS ACCESSIONS SO
I THINK SPECIFICALLY COVERT
NINETEEN HOW ARE YOU DEALING
WITHIN YOUR DEPARTMENT FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE PROTECTION AND
SAFETY OF YOUR STAFF AND HOW IS
THE PANDEMIC AFFECTING YOUR
ABILITY TO FILL. THE
LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVES. IN
GOVERNOR'S INITIATIVES TO OUR
HOUSING. YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THAT QUESTION YEAH WE SPOKE
ABOUT THAT AND LET ME- LET ME
SAY THAT FIND. H. C. V. ED TO
BE JUST AS PRODUCTIVE- PERHAPS
EVEN MORE IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE WE HAVE 75% OVER THE MAN.
WORKING REMOTELY- IN FACT I
BELIEVE THE SECOND OR THIRD
WEEK IN THE JOB I SO THE RISK.
EMPLOYEES FEEL VERY PRODUCTIVE
HELLO OF COURSE WE ARE MY
PHILOSOPHY IS THAT AS LONG AS
THEY ARE PRODUCING RESULTS.
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
STAY SAFE AND HEALTHY AND-
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING. NOW IN THE CONTEXT OFF
OF YOUR QUESTIONABOUT HOW. THE
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT OUR
STOCK REMAINS EXTREMELY ENGAGED
IN THIS FIVE OH OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE SUPPORTING
OUR STAFF WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
WITH THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDING THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE YOU HAVE
THE SUPPORT. TO CITIES COUNTIES.
IN ORGANIZATION WHETHER YOU
STILL ARE FUND PRO. OUR ROLE A
RADIO I AS I SAID IT'S A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
AND SO FORTH. ARE PROBABLY THE
BEST EXAMPLE IS HOME KEEPING
HOME KEEP PROGRAM. TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK MORE. ABOUT
THIS BUT- WE HAVE A TEAM OF
PEOPLE DEDICATED SOLELY TO
PERFORM CONSULTATIONS DAY IN
AND DAY OUT IN THE- OF. ALL OF
OUR OF CAVITE- SO THAT WE
ANSWERED EVERY QUESTION THAT.
WE CAN ANSWER ABOUT THE
VIABILITY THE FEASIBILITY OF
ACQUIRING FACILITIES AT TO MOVE
TO INTERNING AND PERMANENT
HOUSING WE WHERE YOU'RE SEEING.
ALSO INCLUDES WE'RE CALLING
PEOPLE INDIVIDUALLY WORKSHOP
ONLINE WORKSHOPS WEBINARS UNITE
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING USING
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAY TO CON YOU
OUT ASKING. AS POSSIBLE FOR OUR
PORTSMOUTH THIS YOU KNOW DON'T
KEEP OUR EYES OFF OR FORCED
INTO. SAYS WE ENGAGE COMING TO
OUR- TUITIONS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT GIVEN OUR ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY SO OVERALL FUNDING AS
A RITE AID OR AS. A. IN AB VERY
PRODUCTIVE WAY IN DECEMBER WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT AND
JUST MAYBE A- QUICK FOLLOW UP.
YOU DID REFERENCE THE PROJECT
HOME KEY WE NOW STARTED THIS
PROJECT ROOM KEY IS AN
IMMEDIATE REACTION TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN AND- PROVIDING
HOMELESS PEOPLE WITH SHELTER
PLACE TO QUARANTINE IN. THE
NATION OF COURSE TO TRANSITION
FROM TEMPORARY TO PERMANENT
HOUSING AND I BELIEVE. FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED. TO BE DISTRIBUTED TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. A LOT OF
MONEY OVR A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS BUT SPREAD AROUND THE
STATE- HOW HOW IS THAT
DISTRIBUTION GOING AND- WHAT IS
THE LOCAL PARTNER CONTRIBUTION
TO THE STATE FUNDING. RIGHT
THANK YOU STAFF FOR THAT
QUESTION IS- IT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION IS THIS A PROGRAM HOME
GIVE IT WAS ANNOUNCED BY THE
GOVERNOR ONLY A FEW WEEKS AGO
IT'S REALLY MORE THAN A PROGRAM
IS OUR MISSION I WOULD SAY. I
SHELTERS TAKE CARE OF BLOOD
NINE AT NIGHT BERMAN AND
HOUSING TAKES CARE OF HOUSING
INSTABILITY AT ANY PEOPLE HAVE
A STABLE HOME THEY HAVE A PART.
OF THEIR LIFE BACK THEY CAN
CALL IN A FEW STEPS TOWARDS
SELF SUFFICIENCY TERMS ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY- BECAUSE BENEFIT
ANALYSIS WE KNOW THAT ENSURING
OUT THE FIRST HOUSING MODEL
PEOPLE GOING FROM HOMELESSNESS
TO. INTERIM AND PERMANENT
HOUSING IS THE RIGHT MODEL
BECAUSE YOU FACE A LOT MORE
MONEY FROM FROM OTHER SYSTEMS
THAT INCLUDING THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM WE HAVEN'T.
HERE YEAH I THINK THE WAY KNOW
THE SEASON A IS A IS A GREAT
I'LL- I. OFF OF GIVING BRITISH
I THAT MAKE THAT WERE FACING
OUR- AT THIS BOTTOM BUT LOOK.
IN THE GOT HAS RECEIVED BIG THE-
MOUNT SILVA FEDERAL. ASSISTANCE
TO PREVENT RATES OF INFECTION
INCLUDING VULNERABLE PEOPLE
SUCH AS THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND- IT'S KIND OF
BEING AWAY OPPORTUNISTIC HERE
THE HOME DEPOT HOUSES MANY ON
SHELTER CALIFORNIA SINCE THAT'S
WHAT. THE CHALLENGE IS THAT THE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN MAKE RIGHT. TO HIS
ARM DOLLARS EXPIRE AT THE END
OF THE CALENDAR YEAR. SO THAT'S
WHY IT SOON AS THE OPEN OR
ANNOUNCED THE PROGRAM WE
COULDN'T WASTE ANY TIME WE
IMMEDIATELY WENT INTO THE
DESIGN. TO ALL OF OUR- I
GUIDELINE FOR THE PROGRAM WE
SHOULD NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY. ONLY A COUPLE AGO.
BUT I ALL THE INFORMATION THAT
I'M GATHERING FROM MY TEAM. IS
A AYE FEELS MAKES ME FEEL UP.
WE ARE CONTEMPLATING SEVERAL
VIABLE PLANS RIGHT NOW- I
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS
REDDING M. F. FOR SOME OF THESE
FACILITIES TO. MOVE QUICKLY.
GEN I GREW UP WITH FISH
PURCHASING OF MISTRUST
RESENTMENT COM BURNHAM. AT
RIGHT AWAY IN REMEMBER MY NAME
GEN OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
CONSULTATIONS- ARE REQUIRED IN
THAT WOULD BE. NOT I DONE
PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED AS A
PREREQUISITE. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CONSULTATIONS WITH
WITH THE POTENTIAL APPLICANTS
WE ARE REQUIRING THIS YEAR
BECAUSE I GAINES. SURE THAT
WORST. IN THE- EXPAND DEADLINE
AND I BASED ON THE VOLUME OF
CONSUL BASED ON THE GEOGRAPHIC
THIS OF CONSERVE THE NATURE OF
THE PROJECTS THAT WE ARE
HEARING ABOUT- THE READING THIS
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OF PURCHASE JUST
DAYS THAT MEANS UNITS
AVAILABLE. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION THAT I'M
I'M RECEIVING THAT VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME MAKES ME THINK
THAT WE MAY ACTUALLY BE
REALIZED IS GREAT VISION OF THE
GOVERNOR IN USING THIS FUNDS
AND SO FAR IN SUCH A SHORT TIME
WE ALREADY HAVE. A WHEN. I
COMPLETE APPLICATIONS IN THE
CAR SO WE'RE MOVING VERY. I
THIS IS OUR OF A VERY IMPORTANT
PRIORITY AND I WON ADJUSTING
THE LEGISLATURE FOR. THROUGH
THE THROUGH THE PASSAGE OF THE
BUDGET- GIVING ALL THE
AUTHORITY TO SPEND NOT ONLY BE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL. FUNDS FOR
HOME GAME BUT ALSO FIFTY
MILLION ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
HEARING FROM JOHN PAUL THANK
YOU AND I AM RESEARCHER JUST A
QUICK FOLLOW UP ON THAT. AREA
YOU KNOW THE HUGE CHALLENGE IN
SAN THE BAY AREA OUR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES RURAL COMMUNITIES
ELIGIBLE ALSO FOR APPLICATION
FOR THIS PROJECT MONEY HOUSE
HOW DOES HOW DOES YOUR
DEPARTMENT OVERSEE THE
DISTRIBUTION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. YEAH WE ARE FIRM A FIRM
BELIEVER THAT THAT THESE
PROGRAM REQUIRES- ATTENTION IN
TERMS OF THE GEOGRAPH IN THE
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION ACROSS
THE STATE THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
SET ASIDE A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS BY BY REGION- I'M AT
FOR THE FOR- FOR JUST THE STAGE
THE FIRST FEW WEEKS AT THINGS
THE FUNDING AVAILABILITY AND
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
HAS MADE A BET. AND I CAME BACK
ON THE BONES OF THE WE AND
WE'VE BEEN AT COND DOT IT'S SO
YOU CAN SEE THE LIST OF ALL THE
YOU KNOW COUNTY CITIES THAT
HAVEBEEN CALLING ASKING ABOUT
HOW. THIS PROGRAM AND WE SEE IT
YOU KNOW ALL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE YOU KNOW A LOT OF
INTEREST SO I AGAIN THAT I'M
I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT ALSO IN
TERMS OF GEOGRAPHIC THIS. WE
MAY BE ABLE TO SEE GOOD
RESULTS- OF THE END OF THE DAY
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
THESE- THE FACILITIES THAT THEY
ARE- INTENDING TO. TO APPLY FOR
A PURCHASE I ARE VIABLE DAY TO
DAY THERE ARE- THERE FEASIBLE
THAT THAT THERE WILL RANDY- TO
DRINK AND- TO BURNING DURING AN
AND NOT. THING BY. HEY I'M
CAUGHT AND SENT OUT I. ALTHOUGH
WITH YOUR STAFF MAKE SURE THEY
THEY ALSO GETTING FOR ABOUT
WHAT FROM FROM FROM WHICH
COUNTY SAN CITIES APPLICATIONS
THAT WERE ARE ARE COMING FROM
BUT BUT- BUT IT SEEMS THAT WE
ARE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION ALSO
AS A PERTAINS TO GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRICT. THANK YOU SIR- AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING YOUR EXPERTISE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE AT YOUR CONVENIENCE
JUST SEEING THAT CURRENTLY OF
THE- APPLICATIONS THAT YOU'RE
RECEIVING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER MINE
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU THE
SHARE WILK. CAN A DIFFERENT
MEMBER WHO'S. BUT
CONGRATULATIONS ON EUROPE MR
LAST HOUSE AND WE DID HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
TELECONFERENCE AND IT WAS VERY
ILLUMINATING AND YOU HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE BACKGROUND TO STEP
INTO WHAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE HERE PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST ONE WE'VE HAD IN IN OUR
STATE WITH A PANDEMIC A AND
HOUSING ISSUES- AND I'VE SPENT
I THINK WE SPENT MOST OF OUR
DISCUSSION ON THAT PROJECT KEY
THAT WENT FROM PROJECT ROOM KEY
TO PROJECT HOME KEY. AND MY
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN AND ARE
MAKING SURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS THE FUNDING FOR
WHAT THEY'VE ALREADY COME TO
SHARE IF YOU ARE IN MY DISTRICT
ARE WE HAVE AND ROOM KEY ISSUES
ARE A COUPLE OF THE FEDERAL YOU
KNOW ABOUT A YEAR AGO BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS SO IT'S A BIG
ISSUE. I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE
MORE ADD TO THAT I THINK CENTER
MONEY COVERED THE ISSUE DID
HELP ON. ON THIS WAS BEFORE THE
RULES COMMITTEE ARE. LAST MONTH
THE THIS HAD A- ABOUT ELEVEN
THOUSAND MOTEL ROOMS THAT MIGHT
HAVE UNDER KEY. HOME KEY. AND
BUT ONLY 60% OF THEM WERE STILL
OCCUPIED SO THE QUESTION IS DO
WE HAVE AN ISSUE OF. YOU KNOW
HAVING THE ROOMS FIRST AND THEN
TRYING TO GET THE OCCUPANTS
INTO THEM OR ARE WE DOING SOME
SORT OF BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT WE
ARE. LOOKING AT ME WITHOUT
THROUGH THE APPLICATION PROCESS
I'M NOT SURE AND ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET INTO
THEM. OR RECRUITING THEM
THROUGH THE SERVICE THAT ARE
REQUIRED FOR A NUMBER OF THEM.
SO THAT WE HAVE THAT WRAP
AROUND SIR. THAT YOU'LL FIND
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED HOUSING
AND THEN. WITH THE PACKAGE
LET'S SAY OF THIS WRAPAROUND
PROVIDING SERVICES AND THEN. A
HOME ARE WE WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT WE WERE NOT GETTING TOO
MANY ROOMS THAT WE CAN'T BEEN
OCCUPIED BECAUSE CAN'T GET FULL.
WE WORK ON THE BALLOT THERE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK THE- I WANT TO SAY IS
UNDER DO WANNA MAKE THAT THE-
BEWEEN APPROACH ROOM A AND
HOME KEY. TWO DIFFERENT THINGS
AFTER ROOM I WASN'T. TO WERE
POWER OF A BY WORK GROUP BOTH
OF THESE. A ROOM KEY AND HOME
KEY HAVE BEEN- EFFORTS THAT ARE
NOT JUST- ON. ONE SINGLE
DEPARTMENT IT'S BEEN AN EFFORT
LED BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
BETTER WITHOUT A WIDE RANGE OF
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
INVOLVED. WE WERE NOT- I
SYMBOLIC WITH PROJECT ROOM KEY-
I WAS MORE OF A MASTER LEASING
SUPPORT TELLS HIM WHAT TELLS-
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. WAS VERY INVOLVED YES
I THINK I CAN THE NUMBER WAS
CLOSE. TO SIXTEEN THOUSAND
HOTELS AND HOTEL ROOMS- I COULD
JUST JUST TRYING OF CAUGHT. IN
THE INSPECTION IN THIS. BOB YOU
CAN IN MOVING A ANGELS TO NON
COM AT UNITS AND SO THAT WAS SO
OF THE IMPORTANT PRIORITY
IMMEDIATE PRIORITY PART OF THE
EMERGE PUBLIC IN. OUR WHOLE KEY
IS IT'S NOW UP THAT THAT WE ARE
TAKING THE LEAD ON WE ARE NOT
ALONE IN THAT BUT WE ARE TAKING
THESE BECAUSE WE ARE OPERATING
HAS. DIAZ THAT THE FUNDING THE
MECHANISM TO. WHY ARE THESE
FACILITIES PURCHASE FACILITIES
WITH THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT GENERAL MONNING
WAS REFERRING TO. THAT THAT IS
AN APP FOR THAT THAT WE ARE
HEATING AND I. WANNA SAY THAT
IT IS POSSIBLE SENATE OR THAT
SOME OF THOSE. HOTELS MOTELS.
THE FACILITIES THAT WERE USED
ON THE ROOM KEY COULD BE
CONTENT BUT AT A LOCAL
COMMUNITIES MAY BE
CONTEMPLATING- I AM APPLYING ON
THEIR HOME KEY FOR THOSE
FACILITIES BUT BUT WE'VE MADE
HOME Q. A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN JUST HOTELS MOTELS WE'RE
CONTEMPLATING IN ALL OTHER
TYPES OF FACILITIES AND YES I
CAN BE EFFECTIVE IS BECAUSE
THIS IS THE TARGET POPULATION
IS PEOPLE THAT EXPERIENCE.
EXPERIENCE ON THIS VISIT OUR
RISK OF SHOPPING FACT BE THE
IDEA HERE IS TO- RECEIVE
APPLICANTS THAT ARE NOT ONLY
CONTEMPLATING MEDIA. PEOPLE
MEANING TO THE THESE YOUNG BUT
THE REHABBING. AND BE THE
OPERATE AND MAY THIS MISS TO
KEEP THESE FOR A THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND HOUSING FOR THE
INTENDED PER PURPOSE OVER AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME MANY
MANY MAY BE THAT SOME OF THESE
THAT REMAINS AND COUNTIES ARE
WORKING AT THE HOTELS MOTELS
USED FOR ROOM KEY FOR THAT
PURPOSE BUT I BUT IT DOES IT
BOTHER ME IT MY OWN THAT I WHAT
EARLIER THAT THE EIGHT MANY OF
THESE. ARE. GOOD PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING MODELS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES ON
SITE I MEAN THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT HAS WORKED VERY WELL IN
THE PAST AND WE HOPE THAT
APPLICANTS. INCLUDE MODEL. THEY
ARE APPLYING FOR HOME KEEP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT CLARIFICATION AND THAT
DISTINCTION PERFECT THINK
THERE'S A LITTLE CONFUSION
PROBABLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO.
ABOUT ARE WE ACQUIRING THESE
ROOM KEYS WILL THEY BECOME THAT
THE HOME KEY. PROJECT HOME KEY
BECAUSE I THINK OUR DISCUSSION
YESTERDAY WE SPOKE ON BOTH
VERY- CONCERNED ABOUT ENSURING
THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE THERE
THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR.
ALL THOSE BECAUSE HOUSING FIRST
IS IMPORTANT THAT IT DOESN'T
WORK OF FOR A POPULATION THAT
REALLY NEEDS A LOT MORE SERVICE
AND GUIDANCE- IN TERMS OF BOB I
THINK BEING FREE FROM THE
EXPAND THE INDEPENDENCE OF.
FINDING IT ALTHOUGH. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- ARCAND. AND I
WILL BE CHECKING BACK WITH MY
LOCA GOVERNMENT STUFF BEFORE
WE HAVE THE CONFIRMATION VOTE
THAT TODAY I WILL BE ABSTAINING
JUST SO I CAN DIAL BACK IN
ACTUALLY ON PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION AT MY LOCAL. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU
CENTER BATES. CENTER ROTH THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR DIRECTORS
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT MY QUESTION HAS TO
DO WITH FUNDING YOU KNOW MANY
IN THE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
BOTH PROFIT AND NOT FOR PROFIT
AND AT LEAST SOME IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- ARENA CONTEND THAT
THE PROCESS FOR ACCESSING OUR
HOUSING MONEY MONEY FOR
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION.
IS A RATHER BYZANTINE SOMEWHAT
MAYES LIKE DAN RATHER DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE AND I WONDER FIRST
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE- ON THE
ON THAT STATEMENT. THANK YOU
CENTER FOR THAT QUESTION IN MY
OPENING REMARKS I. INCLUDED IN
MY VISION- ESTATE MAN AT
SOMETHING THAT HAD. TO DO WITH
HCV BEING I'M MORE. RELIABLE
PARTNER- AND YOUR QUESTION IS
EXACTLY- WHAT I HAVE NOT
WRITTEN A RESPONSE TO A
QUESTION POSING- IN EXACTLY IN
DIVING ENSURING THAT HCV
THROUGH OUR OUR FUNDING PROCESS
SEES THAT WE ARE FIND THE- THE-
THE EFFICIENCIES TO BE MORE
RELIABLE TO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
I'M PAN AM. MY TIME IN FIRST
THREE MONTHS TALKING WITH.
HOUSING ARE ORGANIZATIONS AFTER
ALL UP AND DOWN THE STATE. FOR
PROFIT NONPROFIT- AND- WHAT I
IS THE DAY THEY WISH- WE WOULD
BE MORE OF YOU KNOW NIMBLE MORE
EXPEDIENT- THAT WE CAN FIND
MORE MORE EFFICIENCY SO THAT-
WE HAVE- THE DAY CAN BE LIVE
BETTER OR NOT SO WE CAN BE MORE
LEVEL MORE CONSISTENT. IN THE
TIMELINES. PROGRAMS YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT- AFTER HEARING
HAVE THIS CONCERNS AND JUST
EXPLORING WHAT ADDITIONAL STEPS
WE CAN TAKE THAT WE ARE WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE THOSE STEPS-
ANYBODY INCLUDES- THE PERHAPS
EVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
SOME CONSOLIDATION OF SOME SOME
PROGRAM SO THAT- THESE. WE CAN
SET UP. YOU KNOW BE OP BE KIND
OF BAD GUESSING YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY ALL OF THESE THEY HAVE
APPLIED ALL OF THESE WHY. WE
HAVE IT'S A MATTER OF FINDING
MORE EFFICIENCIES AS A MATTER
OF BEING- ED LOOKING UP
OPERATIONAL CONSOLIDATION IS
ALSO A FOR A WHILE I MEAN A
LINE ARE OUR DOT WITH. FEDERAL
PRIVATE ACTIVITY BY STOCKS
CRASH YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THESE
APPLICANTS COME TO EIGHT C. H.
C. VI N. FUNDING AND THAT
FUNDING BRIDGE FROM THAT TO
OBTAIN ALL THEIR FUN THAT CAN
GET THIS HORRIBLE THING THAT
THEY GET THIS BROUGHT.
ATTENTION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
OUR OUR- OTHER PROGRAMS A DAY
MAYBE SHE CAN SELL SOME NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN
ALREADY CONSIDERING THAT I'M
TALKING WITH THE LEADERSHIP
TEAM HERE AT EIGHT C. V. THERE
IS OPENNESS TO. AND SURE THAT
ON THE SHIP I WE WILL GET MORE
THIS REGARD WELL SIMPLE ARE
THERE BARRIERS TO STREAMLINE
THIS. AND BY THE WAY IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. FOR A DIFFERENT
APPLICATION TIMELINES THEY MAY
REQUIRE A DIFFERENT SUBMISSION
ALL TO GET A SINGLE PROJECT. UP
AND RUNNING BILTON AND PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY WE'RE TRYING
TO HELP. SO ARE THERE INTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
REMOVE IN ORDER TO PERMIT YOU
IS THE DIRECTOR OF THIS AGAINST
XIN. TO TAX STREAMLINE TO MAKE
THE PROCESS SMOOTHER AND MORE
USER FRIENDLY. HE BOB THE SHORT
ANSWER SATURDAY YES I THINK
THAT THERE ARE- ALL REQUIRE
THAT ARE MANDATED BY STATE THAT
WE TO PAUL. TO YOU KNOW TO NOT
ONLY TIME OF THIS UP TO K. BUT
CREATE THESE REQUIRE ABOUT.
PEOPLE IN THE- INDUSTRY ARE.
YOU EXACTLY I SING THE. THE
DISNEY WHEN THEY THE THEY
CALLED A CHIEF FOR PROPERTY SO
IT IS. TO GATHER MAYBE IT GIVES
US MORE WITHIN OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO FIND SOME.
ADDITIONAL EFFICIENCY STILL TO
BE MORE NIMBLE AND STILL TO
HELP THE INDUSTRY GET THIS
PROJECT OFF THE GROUND OUT MUCH
MUCH FASTER AND- I- I I'M
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
ALL THOSE WHO. TO WE CAN. THE
SOME SOME. WELL I KNOW I SPEAK
FROM COLLEGE ISSUE UNDOUBTEDLY
THOUGH WE HAVE SPENT AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME
AND ENERGY HERE IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING AND WORKING THROUGH
HOUSING ISSUES AND TRYING TO
CRAFT. LEGISLATION TO. ON THE
GROUND ADVENTUROUS OF PER
POINTS TO. HOUSE THE P. OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I KNOW
MY COLLEAGUES AND I. FORWARD TO
WORK WITH YOU TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS A MORE USER FRIENDLY.
OPERATION SO IT MONEY AVAILABLE
WE GET THE MONEY OUT THE DOOR
INTO THE- TO THE DEVELOPERS THE
CITIES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IT
NEEDED IN ORDER TO PUT HOUSING
IN PLACE SO ONE FINAL QUESTION.
WOULD YOU WOULD YOU CAN SET UP.
AS A E. D. A UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION FOR A- BUT SOME.
ANTI COULD MET REYES SEE. TO
QUALIFY FOR AT THE VERY ON THE
PRO A THE SO WE DON'T HAVE DEAL
WITH THESE MULTIPLE OUTPUT FROM
BY THE MONEY WAS MULTIPLE TIMES
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS
AND OUR PROJECT. THANK YOU
SENATOR I THINK THAT THAT IS
EARLY AN OPTION THAT SHOULD BE
ON THE TABLE I'M- THE ONLY.
THING THAT I WOULD TO IS THE
MANY OF THESE YOU KNOW WHERE
WHERE CREATED FOR AN IMPORTANT
REASON LET ME JUST GIVE YOU
YOURSELF JUST A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES YOU KNOW WE HAVE- WITH
OUR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT HE'S SORT ABOUT
IT. AROUND A LOT OF MONEY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE- B. THREE V.
NUMBER POSITION ON THE SAID
THIS UP. THE MEASURE ALL OF THE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WHERE. THAT WERE. ESTABLISHED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION ON THERE AS BE THREE
AND A MULTI. FAMILY HOUSE
PROGRAM SORT OF THE ANCHOR
BROWN. FOR THE FULL PRODUCTION
OF THE SUPPORTABLE. THERE THERE
ARE MANY OTHER PROGRAMS WE HAVE
ENOUGH FOR THE HOUSING SUSTAIN
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE
THAT- HAS- HOUSE AND AT. VERY
SPECIFIC INTENT AND PURPOSE
RIGHT IS REALLY LOOKING AT THE
INTERCEPT. PRODUCTION GOALS WE
MAY HAVE A AN INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GROUND THAT
LOOKS AT THE MINUTE IS THAT
NEED THAT THAT SORT OF OUR-
SUPPORT- AROUND THE AREA WOULD
EVENTUALLY HOUSING WILL BE THE-
THROUGH THROUGH. INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE MAY HAVE TRANSPORT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
THAT LOOKS OF THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN WHERE TRANSIT IS
LOCATED- AND- AND WE'RE
HOUSING. SHOULD BE BUILT AND SO.
THERE YOU CAN ALSO ALL. DAY
ORTON I GREAT VALUE THE BUT THE
PROGRAMS WHERE WE'RE CREATED
BEGIN AND SO WE- IT I WORRIED
THAT WE'RE THINKING ABOUT JUST
YOU KNOW. EVERYTHING INTO ONE
PROGRAM HE COULD BE DUMB BUT-
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO BEGIN. CRAFTING A
PLAN THAT THAT WHERE WE CAN
STILL ACCOUNT FOR H. HOW
APPLICATIONS WHEN THEY ARE
REVIEWING APPROVED WE DON'T
LOSE SIGHT OF THE OBJECTIVES.
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE TO
BEGIN WITH AND YOU KNOW THIS
GETS INTO THE MECHANICS OF HOW
WE COULD RESTRUCTURE THAT REFER
TO I MEAN WE WOULD CALL IT LIKE
A TROOPER THE FUNDING OF IT.
ONE TIME YEAR WHEN THIS BUT BY
THE MID IS MORE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE- THIS PROGRAMS HAVE
AGAIN DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
OBJECTIVES AND SO WE WOULD NEED
TO WE NEED TO BE VERY
METHODICAL READY FOX. HOW WE
WILL CHANGE YOUR I MEAN FOR
SURE INSTEAD OF HAVING IN THE
PROGRAM MANAGER WHO ARE GAY AND
PRETEND HELP PROTECT ORDERS OF
ANY THAT THOSE ROOMS. YOUR
STAFF SERVICES A FACILITATOR
WHO TO THE APP OF THE PROJECT
APPLICATION THAT COMES IN. AND
GIVES. WHAT A HUNDRED UNITS
DOWN ON THE GROUND IN SOMEPLACE
AND YOU SAY WHICH OF OUR
PROGRAMS COULD PROVIDE MONEY TO
HELP FUND THIS PROGRAM ACROSS
PROGRAM DESCRIPTION. BECAUSE
YOU ALONE IN YOUR STAFF WILL
ONLY TRIPOLI UNDERSTAND THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND YOU TAKE THOSE
AND YOU FACILITATE DELIVERY OF
MY- BROAD. FROM WHICH PROGRAM
IT COMES FROM AS LONG AS
APPROACH ROOM QUALIFY IN MY
SENSE RIGHT NOW. WHAT YOU'RE A
DEVELOPER YOU KNOW PROGRAM TO
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL PROBE MANAGER AND
GATEKEEPER OR CHECK ACCOUNT
CHECKING ACCOUNT MANAGER FOR
THE PROGRAM AND TRY TO MAKE
SURE YOUR CAUGHT YOUR PROGRAM
FITS WITHIN THE WITHIN THE
GROUP GAP PLANS OF THE PROGRAM
AND MOVE TO THE NEXT PROGRAM
SEE IF YOU CAN. TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THE PROGRAM AND I
THINK IT WOULD IT'S GONNA
REQUIRE CULTURE YOUR OPERATION.
YOUR PEOPLE UP LOCATION WHEN
THEY COME. US IF I. PRIDE A
PROGRAM NUMBER A PROGRAM A AND
I FORGET TO TALK ABOUT DNC.
NOBODY TODAY OR C. ND NOBODY
MAYBE BRINGS UP C. AND D. SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
WITH YOU AND I KNOW YOU WILL DO
IT I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR-
COMMENTS ABOUT LOOKING AT
STREAMLINED. I MEAN KIRK HERE
TO. I THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX BUT
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX AND SEE
HOW WE COULD REINVENT H. C. D.
TO MORE TO BE MORE USER
FRIENDLY FOR THE FOLKS THAT
COME TO YOU AND DEPEND ON THE
IT SAYS THAT YOU CAN TRY. TO
SOLVE OUR PROBLEM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
HOUSING PROBLEM. THE PROPOSAL
AND FORWARD PUTTING FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION. YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER RAW.
FROM WHAT THE PLEASURES OF LAST
IS THE- THESE FISA. TO AL THE
QUESTION ON THE ISSUES THAT I
DON'T EVEN. INTERESTED IN. SO
WITH THAT WE'RE NOW. GONNA MOVE
ON- TO ANYBODY WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SO A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WISHING
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE.
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE. SIXTY FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHTY FORTY
FIVE THREE FIFTY SIX AND I'LL
DO THAT ONE MORE TIME. ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR NINE ONE SIXTY
THREE SIXTY FOUR IN THIS CODE
IS EIGHTY FORTY FIVE. THREE
FIFTY SIX WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
SEEING NONE- WITH WE WILL MOVE
ON. TO ANY WITNESS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR AND
DIRECTOR. AS SEEING NONE NOW WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
READY TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORBIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTMENT
WE WILL AGAIN. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR
VELASQUEZ YOU'LL PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO PICK UP
THE HANDSET. CORPORATE THE NOT
AGAIN. ONE THEN ZERO. I WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX ONE
TWO SIX THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
AT LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS NONPROFIT PROVIDERS
AND SENIOR CARE AND SERVICES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED PROVIDERS.
IN YOUR HOUSE THANK YOU IN A
SHORT TIME SEEDEATER. POSITION
AND UNDERSTAND IT. THAT HOW THE
NEEDS OF OUR OLD ADULTS PEOPLE.
INCLUDING THAT. HOW. AT THE ON
AIR WE APPRECIATE HIS
COMMITMENT TO BREAKING DOWN
GOVERNOR SILOS TO WORK STATE.
TO ENSURE THAT ONCE HOW OLDER
HEALTH CAN RECEIVE HEALTHCARE
SOCIAL SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE THEY NEED TO REMAIN
SUCCESSFULLY HOW IT'S AN AGE
AND- DROUGHT. IN COURT
PERMISSION THANK YOU GREAT
THANK I SHOULD ALSO A REMINDER
I REMISS TO NOT DO THIS
EARLIER- AND THE FIRST PETER
DID A GREAT GAME. YOUR WITH OR-
AND THEN JUST TO SPEAK- SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY FOR OUR- FABULOUS
STENOGRAPHER WITH THAT
MODERATOR HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE
HAVING Q. IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
THREE MORE IN THE QUEUE OKAY
GREAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED THEN. WHAT ARE MY
NUMBER TWENTY ONE AT FLYNET TWO
ONE WE HAVE THE ONE OKAY.
NUMBER THIS IS TIFFANY. ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY THANK CAN
THAT IS MY NUMBER ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MATT SCHWARTZ CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. AT
A TIME WHEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTIVELY
ROLLING BACK FAIR HOUSING
REGULATIONS MITCHELL A LOT OF
HIS BACKGROUND A LEADING YOUR
BOMB ADMINISTRATIONS FOR OUT
WORK ON TOP THIS. IN WHAT I CAN
DO HELPING PERMANENTLY FOR
HOUSING MAKES HIM A
PARTICULARLY ASSET AND LEADER.
HEY THE PARLIAMENTARY HE'S
DAMAGED TO MY TEAM WELL AS MY
PEER IT IS LEADERSHIP IN AND
EXTERNALLY AND IT CAN. TO
MAKING THE DEPARTMENT BEST
POSSIBLE THERE YOU ARE EVERYONE
BRING TO HELP BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOMES CROPS STATE. WITH CHARLIE
PURCHASE CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU SIR. WE WILL GO NEXT JULY
NUMBER FOURTEEN THAT IS LINE
ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GERMAN MICHAEL GUNNING WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT DIRECTOR VELASQUEZ. I
HAVE TO ADMIT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH HIM ON A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS. VERY EXCITED ABOUT
HIS LEADERSHIP AND BANK THE MAP
FOR MENTIONING HIS BACKGROUND
AND BREADTH OF EXPERIENCE AND
WE FULLY SUPPORT IT MASON AND
HOPE YOUR BOWTIE IF YOU. CAN MR
GUNNING. STONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE HERO. YOU HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR. OKAY NOW THAT WE'VE
DONE SUPPORT AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GONNA AND MOVE ON TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
THERE WE WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HERE. HE OPPOSITE.
SO THAT'S FIRST BEGIN HERE WITH
ANYONE ELSE'S IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHICH WHICH WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE-
AND I'M STRUGGLING TO SEE
ANYONE THERE SO I DON'T THINK
THEY ARE. BUT THIS POINT ON
WE'LL GO BACK TO MODERATE SO
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
POINT AND WE WILL BEGIN. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TEST. IN
OPPOSITION OF DIRECT VELASQUEZ
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION YOU WILL
PRESS. THEM ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU HAVE NO
ONE IN HE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE WELL I MET A MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD JUST DO THAT ONE
MORE AND I MEAN I'M PRETTY
CONFIDENT THERE'S NO WHEN THEY
BUT JUST WANNA DO MY DUE
DILIGENCE SO IF YOU COULD. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF DIRECTOR
VELASQUEZ. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT IS ONE. THEN
ZERO. THE DATE THAT'S A SIGN OF
NO ONE CARING RIGHT THE STAFF
THEY'LL SURPRISE THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR. SO AT THIS
POINT WE WILL GET BACK TO
MEMBERS FOR ANY FURTHER JUST
TEN OR DIGITAL COMMENTS. MOVE
THE NOMINATION. FAITH. NO
VOTING ON THE NONVOTING MINING
I MONEY I ROTH AYE ROTH AYE
WILK HI LOOK I AT. NOT HERE. SO
ON CALL SO WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR THE FOR THE PRO TEN
AND THEN MISTER DIRECTOR NEW.
GIVE OUR CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOUR APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR BIZARRE
SCENOGRAPHER NEED TO TAKE A
BREAK OR CAN. WE DO ONE MORE.
ONE MORE OKAY. K. NEXT UP WE
HAVE MS KIMBERLY. BURKE MEYER
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. SHE COMING UP.
WELCOME WE GET IT WE CAN SEE
YOU CAN YOU SEE US YES I AM
OKAY RIGHT WELL WELL AND AT
THIS POINT THERE'S ANYONE LIKE
A INNER REDUCE GIVE TO MANY
MOVING TO WEAR ANY OPENINGS TO.
GREAT THANK YOU ONE. AFTERNOON
VICE CHAIR WILK IN. MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY MY AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OF CAN AFFAIRS
MY THANKS TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AGENCY SECRETARY CASTRO RAMIREZ
COMMITTEE STAFF AND MEMBERS FOR
ATTENDING NEED TO JOIN YOU. HEY
ONLY. THE LIVING SUPPORT OF MY
FAMILY MY HEALTH. AND MY SON
HARRISON I WOULD LIKE TO
PUBLICLY THANK THEM FOR THEIR
IN DURING SUPPORT AND PATIENCE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STARTED UP
THE ONE YEARS AGO AS A STUDENT
ASSISTANT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. TODAY THE
DIRECTOR I CAN ONLY DESCRIBE
THIS AS COMPLETE AN AWESOME. IT
DEPARTMENTS MISSION OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION FORMS THE CORE OF MY
PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER. BERMAN
IS MADE UP OF THIRTY SEVEN
LICENSING BOARDS AND BUREAUS
THAT LICENSE MORE THAN THREE
POINT FIVE. MILES IN CALIFORNIA
OVER MY THIRTY ONE YEARS AT THE
DEPARTMENT I WORKED AT BOTH A
HEALING ARTS BOARD ANY NON
HEALING ARTS FOR. AND MOST
PLEASE I CAN DIRECT MEDICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA. APPLIES AND FORCE.
STATION BY THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ME FOR THIS. AND HAS ALSO
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
HOW I APPROACH TO FLUIDITY OF
THE KOBE NINETEEN AND- SINCE MY-
LAST FALL IMMEDIATELY UTILIZE
MY STRONG RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE BOARDS AND BUREAUS TO
IMPROVE RELATIONS BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT THE PROGRAM. YEAH
SERVICE COMMUNICATE FREE AND WE
EXCHANGE IDEAS. THE BORDER ZERO
EXECUTIVES ARE AMONG THE MOST
DEDICATED AND PASSIONATE PEOPLE
I HAVE WORKED WITH AND I
CONTINUE TO LEARN FROM THEM
DEEPLY I AM ALL FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND I'M BRING LEADERS
AS CALIFORNIA'S TOP. INTO THESE
AS RECTOR. RESPONSIBILITY AND
PROTECTION THE LENS BY WHICH
MIGHT ARE FILTERED MY IMMEDIATE
GOALS INCLUDE ADVANCING
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY THROUGHOUT
DC A PROGRAMS. DO YOU SEE THESE
SERVICES TO THE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS SO THEY IN TURN BETTER
SERVE THEIR LICENSEES AND THE
CONSUMERS. USING DATA
TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP EFFICIENT
STRATEGIES TO DRIVE DOWN
LICENSING AND ENFORCEMENT TIME
FRAMES. INCREASING THE TIMELINE
TAKES TO ENACT REGULATIONS AND
MOST IMPORTANT TO ALL OF YOU
ENSURING LEGISLATION THAT GETS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
IGNED INTO LAW BY THE GOVERNOR.
IS FULL OF AMENDED BY THE
PARLIAMENT AND THE BORDER POST.
THE PAST FIVE MONTHS OKAY NIGHT
IN. UNCERTAIN ALLY HOW IT HAS
PROVIDED AN INVALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE HOW WE CAN
DO STATE GOVERNMENT
DIFFERENTLY. TO GATHER WITH.
YEAH WE ARE REVIEWING BUSINESS
PROCESSES HELP STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE COSTS IMPACT BOTH
LICENSEES AND CONSUMERS I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
THE LEGISLATURE ON IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE DEPARTMENT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- SENATE FOR THE UP.
BEAT THE FUTURE OF THE ISLAND
THANK YOU SO MUCH GREAT THANK
YOU IF THAT. I'M GONNA MOVE TO
MY LIPS MINING. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN LET ME OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS AS WELL- TO
DIRECTOR KIRK MYRON TO THANK
YOU FOR A CAREER OF SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CHANCE TO CONVERT
THE FROM I THINK SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO KIND OF
REPEAT FOR THE BAND OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE POP.
I'M KIND OF SURE COVERT
NINETEEN HOW THAT'S AFFECTING
YOUR STAFF IN THE MANY- SOME
BOARDS AND AGENCIES THAT YOU
HAVE OVERSIGHT. WELL LET'S
START THERE AND THEN HAD A
FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC IMPACT ON EXTERNALLY
ON COVERT NINETEEN THANK YOU
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR MONEY
I THINK THE CALL THE OTHER DAY
IT WAS GREAT TO SEE WITH YOU. I
DID NOT INTEND AMERICANS HIT
THE APART. PORTED ROSE WITHIN
THE- SO THE FIRST THING THAT IS
WE NEEDED AFTER IN FACT DIDN'T
MAKING OUR EMPLOYEES STAY AT
HOME THE FIRST THING WE NEED TO
DO IS LOOK AT THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM AND I'LL- HOW
CAN WE GET OUR EMPLOYEE TO BE
A- WORK FROM HOME. AND STILL.
SERVICE IT WOULD PROVIDE TO THE
LAST TWO CONSUMERS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE OFTEN OF THE-
SYSTEMS THEY WE- FORWARD AND-
THEM. OUR INDIVIDUALS TO BE
ABLE TO WORK HOME AND AGAIN
ARTICLE ARE OUR BREAD AND- THEY
REALLY ARE END OF THE WE NEED
TO PROTECT AND SO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN HAVE THEM WORKING
FROM HOME NOT OLD. LAPTOP I.
THANK THE END. THE DATA IS.
THOSE ARE INDIVIDUALS BE TO
THOSE DATABASES FROM HOME WHILE
STILL MAINTAIN SO AND THEN. AND
SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE DID I THINK WE ARE
ABLE 28% OF OUR INDIVIDUALS
SHOULD BE TO BE THIS. WELLS I'M
I'M- FOR SOME IN THE IN NEED AT
THIS IN THE- AND THAT ARE.
DURING AN ARM MALE SIR. AND
THOSE. ARE ABOUT WE SURE THAT
WE I'M GIVING. IT PP. SO THIS
THING WHERE FOR EACH OF THE
INDIVIDUALS. AND THE OTHER
THING THAT WOULD BE REALLY GET
INTO. YOU IT TURNED OUT. A LOT
OF COMMUNICATION. BUT THEN I
ALSO GET THAT IN. OUT TO ALL OF
OUR LIFE. AND WE UTILIZE SOCIAL%
MEDIA WE UTILIZE EMAILS AND
THEN WE ALSO UTILIZED- EMAILS
TO THE LICENSEES IN PARTICULAR.
I'M ALSO GETTING THAT
INFORMATION OUT TO CONSUMERS
AND MAKING ANY CHANGES POSTED
ON OUR WEBSITE. THEY WOULD
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS GOING ON
THERE WAS GUIDANCE THAT WAS
BEING PROVIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA. HELLO AND WE TO
MAKE SURE IMPACT ARE SO LIKE
BASE THAT WE SURE IN WERE ABLE
TO OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION SO
WE POSTED THAT ON OUR WEBSITE
AS WELL AND THEN LOOKING REALLY
TO HELP PUBLIC AND CONSUMERS WE
REALLY STARTED OUT WE MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LIVES BECAUSE SINCE
HE'S A REAL BASIS IN.
INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE TWO
WORLDS AND SO WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY COULD CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE BECOMING POSSIBLE KOBE
NINETEEN. AND SOME OF THE
THINGS WE LOOKED AT AS SOME OF
OUR LAWS AND REGULATIONS NEEDED
TO BE A WAIT IN ORDER FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO.
PERFORM THEIR SERVICES. AND IN
LICENSE OR GET LICENSE AND SO
WE ACTUALLY MET WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION I'M WITH OUR
AGENCIES SECRETARY AND REALLY.
WELL TO PUSH FORWARD EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT THE UNDERSIGNED THAT
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR
OF CELLS TO FIND. WEAVER'S
FIRSTPRIZE AND SO AS SOON THAT
AND THAT WAS RELEASED OVER THE-
WE RECEIVE A BIT ALMOST HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TO REQUETS FOR
WAIVERS- AND WE WERE LOOKING AT
THOSE FROM A LARGE POPULATION
OF IT YOU KNOW HOW IT. CAN
IMPACT A LARGE GROUP. ORANGE
BOWL SOME OF THE ONES WE ISSUED
WEDNESDAY I'M WAITING SOME OF
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTINUING
EDUCATION SO INDIVIDUALS COULD
STILL REMAIN LICENSE. AND THEN
ALSO THERE WERE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAD RECENTLY RETIRED SO
BRINGING THEM BACK INTO. THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE AS WELL AND
THEN WE ALSO WORKED OUTSIDE OF
EVEN THAT WE PROCESS IN.
TESTING THE- JUST BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF THE WORD THE BEING
ABLE TO IN THE- FROM. OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO SEE IN
ANY SEARCH THAT MAY HAPPEN. SO
WITH ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT'S
REALLY HOW- WE'VE REALLY BEEN
IMPACTED BY HOPE NINETEENTH ONE
RATING IS THAT WE USE. WITH FEW
EXCEPTIONS WITHIN OUR LICENSING
BOARD IMPERILS. TO MAKE IN THE
WORKABLE BOTH LIFE AND ENFORCE.
AND OBVIOUS SOMETHING WE HAD
THE- WITH DOING INTERVIEWS OVER
THE PHONE RATHER THAN IN
PERSON- BUT DEFINITELY THAT HAS
BEEN HAPPENED THEN. THE JUST
MENTIONED IS THAT ALL OF OUR ON
BOARDS IN THE THIRTY SEVEN
BOARDS EMBARRASSED. OUR WORDS
HAVE. AMY THE END BUSINESS. I
THINK THAT TO BE ABLE TO AND
THAT'S CURRENT THAT WE'RE IN
AND SO WE ENDED UP UP WHAT FOR
OUR BOARD MEMBER IN OUR T.
UNITED STEP IN THERE AND REALLY
HELPED OUT AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO GET ON BOARD SPEAKING ABOUT
WEBEX WHICH- I DON'T. SEE
TROUBLE WITH. MORE ON COMMUNITY
TO THE BOARD BY ALLOWING THAT
OUTSIDE REMOTE ACCESS SO IT'S
BEEN A DIFFERENT WORLD AND IT'S
SOMETHING I THINK THAT WE'VE
AND- ACTUALLY WE HAVE- BUT IT
WILL. I JUST PEOPLE RELEASED TO
THE PLATE AND PROTECT OUR
MARCIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT COMPREHENSIVE AND SERRANO.
IN OUR CONVERSATION WE FOCUSED
AND ALSO ON SOME OF THE
WAIVERS. ALLOWING NURSING
STUDENTS TO. CHANGE THE
DIMENSION OF THE PRACTICAL
TRAINING VERSUS ONLINE AND
GETTING PEOPLE THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY ORDERS
ABLE SPONTE TO THE CRISIS SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THERE TOO. I THINK MY I DON'T
QUIT WHEN WE WERE DONE THIS
WHEN WE SPOKE- PRIOR TO YOUR
SUMIT DIRECTORSHIP THERE WAS
THE STATE ORDERED REVIEW OF THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
AND THEN IN. A SUBSEQUENT
INVESTIGATION OF SOME.
DIRECTORS IN THAT DEPARTMENT-
ALSO FINING. RECORDS PLANNING
TO DECEIVE THE STATE AUDITOR
YOU DID TELL ME THAT THAT
SUBJECT TO AN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION SO SOME OF IT IS
CONFIDENTIAL. HOW IN YOUR
POSITION. WITH SO MANY BOARDS
AND AGENCIES AND COMMISSIONS
HOW CAN YOU AS DIRECTOR.
GUARANTEE INTEGRITY IN IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND AGENCIES STAFF
MEMBERS- IN MAY BE USING THIS
AS AN EXAMPLE RESPECTING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY. HOW CAN BE
SURE THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE
AND THEN CEREMONY BUT BEFORE
YOU ACT YOU ANSWER MADAM
DIRECTOR AND I HAVE THE SAME
CHALLENGE I LIKE TO TALK PASSED
ON AND WE HAVE WE HAVE A
STENOGRAPHER SHE'S HAVING A
HARD TIME KEEPING UP WITH YOU.
SO ALSO OKAY GREAT MUCH ALL
RIGHT I'M SORRY. B. R. IT CAME
OUT JUST TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
IS SOMETHING WHEN IT WHEN IT
WAS RELEASED AND WHEN IT CAME
TO US AND WE WERE- WE SEE BACK
ON IT IT WAS SOMETHING WE TOOK
VERY SERIOUSLY- INTEGRITY
ENTRANCE IN. IMPORTANT YOU I'M
NOT ONLY THE DEPARTMENT TOO BUT
INDIVIDUAL HE- REVIEWS THAT
REALLY AS A LEARNING EXPERIENCE
FOR US AS USUALLY IF YOU KNOW
THE- GOOD THING SO WHEN THEY
COME. FORWARD THAT SOMETHING WE
WANT TO DO. WELL REALLY YEAH
THIS IS WE- DID INVESTIGATE
STARKEY INVESTIGATION INTO THE
MATTER AS WELL BECAUSE WE HAD
TO HAVE IT SEPARATE FROM THE
BUREAU'S ON ITS WAS. AT WE TALK
ABOUT. THAT PERSONNEL RUSSIAN
NOT IT REALLY IS SOMETHING
THAT'S CONFIDENTIAL BUT I DO
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW IT IS
BEING AND- IT. AND ACTUALLY IN.
INVESTIGATE AS FAR AS WHAT WE
ARE. GOING FORWARD AND- OUR
THAT. A LIST MYSELF AND WE WILL
HAVE TO MENTION THAT THAT FOR
OF REGISTER NURSING ON IT JUST
TO MAKE SURE THE IN. NOW
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROVIDING. WE WILL HAVE THE
INTAKE THAT. NEEDED TO PROVIDE
IN. THAT IS TO COME FROM AND
TRUTH FROM THE- THAT YOU HAVE.
ON THE OTHER THING THAT WE
REALLY LOOKED AT IS MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN WE DO HAVE A- STATE
AUDIT REPORT BECAUSE AGAIN THIS.
LITTLE I THINK THERE. YOU'RE A
STAY AUDIT REPORT. MAKE SURE
GOING FORWARD THE PART IS
INVOLVED ANY OF RISKS AND THE
DEPART BILITY TO GO IN OUR DATA
AND LOOK AT THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING TO MAKE SURE I
IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE IN THEIR
SHOES A QUICKLY BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE IDEA. AND
CHECKING IN FROM THAT'S BEING
PRO. AND FROM EACH THE FORD AND
YOU TOUCH ON A BOARD THOSE ARE
MY MUST. TO WHERE- THEY
UNDERSTAND WHEN WE'RE COMING IN
AND ASKING FOR THIS INFORMATION
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO BE
HELPFUL TO THEM I'M TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES AS WELL
AS WE THEM TO COME FORWARD TO
US WITH ANY PROBLEMS THAT THEY
MAY HAVE AND ESPECIALLY ME
COMES UP WHAT HOW HARD IT IS.
TO THERE'S- ALL THIS BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE WE ARE ANSWER THEM
APPROPRIATE. AND I THINK
BUILDING CAN YOU. BACK AND
FORTH WILL BE ONE THE BEST WAYS
HELP. FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR RESPONSES ARE. THAT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN- BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
ANY OF US WOULD WANT TO SEE
HAPPEN AGAIN. AND AGAIN WORKING
WITH I JUST I KNOW THAT. YES OF
COURSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALSO WORKING THE
PLEDGE OF AS THEY REVIEW THE
BOARD AND MAKES THAT WE'RE
MAKING THE RIGHT DECISIONS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
ON. WHAT RIGHT BEING A TUNE
FROM THE SHIP IS. OF
EXPECTATIONS OF ALL OF YOUR-
AGENCY DIRECTORS AND STAFF SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. THANKS TO OUR
STENOGRAPHER FOR KICKING A CASE.
THANK YOU OKAY. HER MOM SENATOR
BATES. WELL CONGRATULATIONS
MAYES. DIRECTOR KURT MEYER AND-
LET ME START WITH A ACTUALLY OF
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE CAREER PATH WITH AN
INSPIRATION TO YOUNG WOMEN
STARTING OUT I THINK IT WAS
LIKE A STUDENT INTERN IN
FINDING YOUR WAY ALL THE WAY TO
POP IN ABOUT SORT OF A- PATH WE-
AGE ALL OUR YOUNG. ACTUALLY ARE
ARE YOUNG. PURSUE IT AND FIND
THEMSELVES OF THE THROUGH THE
GLASS CEILING OF WE FAITHFUL
OUT CONGRATULATIONS CERTAINLY
ON BASS ACTUALLY YOU ANSWERED
ON MOST OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE
YOU KNOW FOCUSED ON IN IN THE
BACKGROUND HERE I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING I. SET THE
CALL. I DID OF THE MANY RULES
AND- THAT. ARE SEEM TO HAMPER
IF NOT HAMPER AT LEAST BURDEN
ARE PROFESSIONALS IN OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NOW WE THANK YOU
FOR THE- TITANS YOU PROVIDED
CERTAINLY FOR OUR PERSON. SALON
AND BARBER SET OF COULD
CONTINUE TO DO SOME OF THEIR
BEST A FLOP IN. THE OUTDOOR.
I'M TURN WHETHER THERE'S
PLANNER TAKING A LOOK AT THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THERE. THROUGH
THE PAN MAKE CARE PROFESSIONALS.
WILL BE ALLOWED TO COME BACK
INTO PRACTICE I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO NEED THEM WE'RE GOING
TO NEED THEM PASSED ALL THIS
VERY CHALLENGING. TIME ALSO ARE
IN FORM FOR ANYONE OF THE
BUSINESSES ARE THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN
OUT AND PROVIDED. OPPORTUNITY
FOR WAIVERS. SENATOR THIS IS
MAN YOU KNOW IT SOME YOU JUST
HAVE TIME TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING
I THINK. BUSINESS PROCESS
BECAUSE YOU'RE SO BUSY DOING
THE WORK IN FRONT OF YOU AND
COLBY NINETEEN HAS FORCED US TO
WORKING EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE
DOING TO LOOK AT DIFFERENTLY
AND I MENTIONED THAT MY OPENING
STATEMENT BECAUSE- I THINK THIS
HAS REALLY. BEEN US TO LOOK AT
OUR- IS THIS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD TO INTO
THE FUTURE- WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED LOOKING AT LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.TATIAN AND
ALLOWING MORE ITEMS TO BE
ONLINE I'M A LOT OF OUR LAWS
ARE EITHER RIGHT OR REGULATIONS
ARE OUTDATED AND- EDUCATION
FEEL. THE REQUIREMENTS ARE MORE
FOR BEING IN PERSON LIKE THAT
BUT NOW WITH TECHNOLOGY YOU'RE
ABLE TO AYE YOU KNOW JENNIFER I
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE ON AND
MAKE SURE THEY'RE TAKING ANY SO
THAT'S SOMETHING. THAT WE HAVE
IN OUR BOOK. FUTURE. IF I
REVERSE IT BEEN AROUND THAT
LOOKING AT THOSE LAWS TO SEE IF
THEY'RE OUTDATED SO BOTH OF
THOSE ITEMS ARE. WHERE WE NEED
TO LOOK AT WITH OUR
REINSTATEMENT IMAGE COMING BACK
INTO THE PRACTICE THAT'S
SOMETHING THEY HAVE THE
CAPABILITY RIGHT NOW WE JUST
ACTUALLY WAIVE SOME OF THE
IMMEDIATE REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW
THEM TO COME IN A LITTLE BIT
QUICKER. THEY WOULD HAD TO
ADDRESS THIS IS AND GET. AND SO
WE- WILL TO WHERE THEY BACK IN.
I'M THIS FOR CERTAIN OF TIME TO
COME BACK IN IF THEY DO PAY
THAT WE FEE AND WE THOSE COULD
AND REQUIREMENTS SO WE JUST
WAIT DEFINITELY MAKE SURE THOSE
IN THE BILL I COULDN'T WITH YOU
MORE WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW LONG
THIS GOING ALLOW. WE WANT TO
SURE WE- AS INDIVIDUALS HERE.
THAT THEY NEED TO IT WAS YOU
KNOW IT WAS GRAY THE L. OF IN
THE STEP TO THE AND ABLE COME
IN AND GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS
OF REINSTATEMENT BUT DEFINITELY
THERE'S A LOT OF LESSONS
LEARNED THROUGH THIS PROCESS
INCLUDING THE LOOKING AT THE
WAY WE DO BUSINESS WITH OUR
BOARD MEETINGS THEMSELVES.
MAYBE MAKE CHANGES. FEDERAL TO
BE ABLE TO COME INTO THOSE ME
AS WELL. WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT TO YOU HAVE I THINK A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF THE
DUTIES BEFORE YOU AND THE
CHALLENGES AND I THINK I HEAR A
REAL DESIRE THAT SHE'LL LEAVE
YOUR MARK. ON THIS WHOLE AREA
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND
CERTAINLY OF THE HEALTH AND.
WELFARE OF OUR OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY THROUGH I LIKE TO SEE
A MORE ENFORCEMENT PROCESS TO.
OF OUR SHAKHTAR WIN IT COMES
TROOPERS AND FIND. LIVE THING
AND JOE THEM ALL WHAT FOR IS
LITIGATION. THANKS FOR THEM OUT
OF SCHOOL I FEEL THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TAKE A LOOK AT
AQUELLOS SPECS FOR THAT PROBLEM
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT JOB WHERE
ARE GOVERNMENT RELATES THE
PEOPLE AND WE WANT THEM TO HAVE
A VERY VERY POSITIVE FEELING
ABOUT OUR GOVERNMENT. OKAY WILL
CONTINUE TO SURVIVE AND PROVIDE
TO ALL OF US GREAT OPPORTUNITY
HAD IT THREE CHANCE THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE SUPPORT LOOK FOR TO
THE MISSION AND WE GET. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU CENTER.
SENATOR ROB THANK YOU MISS
CHAIR OF MEN DIRECTOR. I
COLLEAGUE GUESTS OF ABOUT THE
BORDER NURSE HAVING DO WITH THE
REPORT BUT AND THE REPORTING OF
IN FOR. BUT SEPARATE OF FROM
THE- THERE BEEN SOME OF SOME
KIND MAYBE I'LL- THAT- IN THE
NOT TOO DISTANT PAST THE BOARD
HAS. TAKEN ACTIONS TO. LIMIT
VARIOUS NURSING SCHOOLS
ENROLLMENT THAT SOME CONTENT.
WERE IN EXCESS OF THE AUTHORITY
SET OUT IN THE REGULATIONS AND
YOU MENTIONED THE THESE BOARDS
ARE SEMI AUTONOMOUS WHAT WHAT
ROLE DOES THE DEPARTMENT PLAY
IN TERMS OF OVERSEEING THE
ACTIONS. TAKEN TOWARDS WITH
RESPECT TO IN THIS CASE-
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS WERE
EDUCATING AND EVENTUALLY
TURNING OUT YOUR LICENSEES. I
THINK THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
WAYS TO LOOK AT THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE I'M FIRST OF ALL THERE
ACTUALLY ISN'T A SEPARATE AUDIT
FOR THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING PARTICULAR TO THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT YOU
MENTIONED WITH THE SCHOOLING
AND SO AGAIN GOING BACK TO WHAT
I TALKED ABOUT WITH THE OTHER
ON IT THIS IS SOMETHING WE'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH THE- I
JUST. NURSE ON AND MEET. THEY
ARE FOLLOWING THE OR THAT AMEND
THEIR REGULAR TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES THAT THEY SEE NECESSARY
AFTER REVIEWING THE NURSING
EDUCATION PROGRAMS I'M JUST
ALREADY WE'VE HAD A LOT OF THE
NURSING EDUCATION PROGRAMS COME
FORWARD WITH THE COLLUDED ISSUE
WHEN TRYING TO GET THOSE
CLINICAL SO IT'S SOMETHING
WHERE WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
WORKING WITH THE BOARD AND
REGISTER PERSON WE- I. THOUGHT
THAT. MEETINGS THEM TO MEET
WEEK KIND LOOKING ALL OF IS BUT
WE REALLY WANT TO I. THAT
PROCESS WHAT THEY GO THROUGH
THE OTHER THING THAT WE DO AS A
DEPARTMENT AS WE PRO LEGAL. OUR
BOARDS AND- WITH THOSE LEGAL
COUNSEL INDIVIDUALS GUY GIVE
GUIDANCE TO THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
THEIR PROGRAMS ON AS THEIR
REVIEWING THEIR PROCESSES WANT
TO MAKE SURE IS THERE'S
CONSISTENCY- THEY DO HAVE A NEW
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING WAS JUST
NOW AND ONE OF THE BEST IT'S
JUST THAT. IT'S A NURSING
EDUCATION. TO THIS. THE GREAT
ON WHAT AT HIS NURSING AND
PROGRAM AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE- REVIEWING THEM
APPROPRIATELY AND THEN FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS YOU WE TEN THE
BOARD MEETINGS AS WELL AS FOR
AT LEAST NOW WE'RE WATCHING
THEM BUT WE ARE ALL OF THE
BOARD MEET. THEY PUT THE ON
THESE. PROGRAMS AND WHERE WE
SEE FIT WE MAY NEED TO STEP IN
AND GIVE GUIDANCE AND GIVE
ASSISTANCE TO- THE DIFFERENT
PORTS NOT JUST THE REGISTERED
NURSE ANY BOARDS THIS THING
THAT WE DO. WE REVEAL ALL OF
THE BOARD. THANK AND THAT. THE
WORLD WHERE. WHAT SCHOOL ON
WITH THE BOARDS AND BERYL.
PRIOR TO COMING OVER I AT A AT
THE- ON PREVIOUS. HAD IN A
POINT AS A BOY ZERO RELATE
DECCA DIRECTOR. AND SO I KNOW
AS AN- DIRECTOR ONE OF THE
FORESTRY THINGS. AN EXACT JOB
AT AT AN ON THE BOARD PREVIOUS
WAS THAT DEPARTMENT MAY NOT IT
WAS NOT FOLLOWING WHAT WE WERE
DOING AND THEN THEY WOULD ASK
WHEN IT WAS TOO LATE SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS WE WILL. CARE.
AND THE PROBLEM. OR FOLLOW AND
WHERE IT WAS ON THE EXECUTOR
RIGHT JOB RIGHT THEIR BOARDS
AND THAT WE CAN BE ANY SAID
ASSISTANCE AND THEM DO THE
BETTER THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE
TO DO. WELL THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU DO THANK YOU THAT VERY
COOPER RISK I. HIS ONE OF. WHAT
THE QUESTION YOU THANK FOR MY
FOR PICTURE HERE I. WAS THE
CHAIR OF A SUB THAT WAS STATED.
LOCAL AS A RESULT I HAD MORE TO
DO WITH IT PROJECTS AND I EVER
WANTED TO HAVE IN MY ENTIRE
LIFE AND SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON
THE BREEZE PROJECTS SO. I
NOTICED THAT IN SOME OF MY
NOTES JUST WHAT AND WHAT THE
TIMELINE WAS. BOND IN ONE
SYSTEM NINE OR TEN OF. CONSUMER
DEPARTMENT COULD AFFAIRS TO T.
THAT. BILL FOR IN TERMS OF THE
NEW COMPUTER SYSTEM. SO WE HAVE
SEVENTEEN AS A SENATOR I JUST
HAVE TO TAKE THIS MINUTE JUST
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I REMEMBER
TESTIFYING IN FRONT YOU WERE
ONE OF THEM IT SHOULD THE
BUDGET CHAIR AND ONE. CLICK IT
WAS GREAT WE USE **** OUR STAFF
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO MEET THE
INFORMATION THEY PUT IN THE
DATABASE IS ACCURATE BECAUSE
YOU ACCESS THE NUMBER NUMBER.
OF QUESTIONS INCLUDING ON
STATISTICS AND SO WE WANTED TO
GO BACK AND TELL THEM THIS IS
WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT WHAT YOU
DO BECAUSE YOUR YOUR WHAT YOU
DO IS. HELLO YOUR QUEST. WELL
WE GOT THIS AT ISSUE WE HAVE
SEVENTY BOARDS IN WHO WERE NOT
BROUGHT INTO THE SYSTEM AND
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH A
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PROCESS
WE HAVE. ZEROES RIGHT NOW GOING
THROUGH COURT I'M AND SO THE
PLAN IS TO GET INDIVIDUALS INTO
THE PROCESS BY THE IN THE
MIDDLE OF TWENTY ONE. ONCE EACH
OF THE ADDITIONAL BOARDS AND
BUREAUS ARE BEING BROUGHT INTO
CONCORD SO THEY'RE JOINING
TOGETHER WHERE EACH OF THOSE
BOARDS HAVE SIMILAR PROCESSES
THERE JOINING TOGETHER. TO KIND
OF GO USE THE SYSTEM TO HELP
THEM WE LEARNED SO MUCH FROM.
SORRY SO MUCH FROM THE PROCESS
THAT WE WENT THROUGH WITH PRES-
HOW IMPORTANT ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT AS- AND SO
THAT'S ONE THING WHERE WE HAVE
THE OFFICE OF ORGANIZATIONAL
IMPROVEMENT THIS WAS BEING OUT
OF THE STATE EIGHTEEN BOARDS
AND BUREAUS TO PUT. PLANS THE
ROLL OUT WORKING WITH THEIR
STAFF WERE ALSO LEARNING FROM
FIRST. WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
WILL WORK IN THE FIRST COHORT.
OF THE FEW MEMBER MEMBER BOARDS
THEN. BOARD MEMBER. OTHER
BOARDS WILL BE A TO LEARN FROM
THE IN THE- AND ALSO BE ABLE
USE OF THOSE. SO THEY DON'T TO
READ THE WHEEL. OVER OR HOPING
FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS ²DID
THE BILL OUR CORE ONE ARTICLE
USE JUST BECAUSE OF RESOURCES
THAT THEY WILL BE GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THEIR
PROCESS. AND THAT UP THE NEW
COUPLE. IT THE NET YEARS WE
WILL BE BRINGING IN TO A NEW.
INNOVATION WOULD WON'T BE THREE
AT LEAST FOR THIS CALL IS. ON
THE BRINGING INTO A SET THAT WE
CAN USE FOR ALL OF THE SAN
BOARD GIRLS OUT OF. AMAZING
WERE HE SAID. FOR WILL GET YOU
EVERYWHERE I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION
CONGRATULATE YOURSELF LET'S. WE
LEARNED GENERAL ROSS SO HEAD
OUT PLEASURE OF AN EFFORT FOR A
COUPLE WITH THE WITH THE
GENERAL N. THAT SUB COMMITTEE
ANYWAY CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND IT IT IS A
REMEMBER MIRACULOUS CAREER. AND
SO IT OBVIOUSLY. WORKED IN
EVERY NOOK AND CRANNY SURE
BENEFIT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA GREATLY- OUR MOST
QUESTIONS ARE POSITIONS EIGHT
YOU'VE ALREADY DRESSED IN AND
DONE IT WELL SO CONGRATS ON
THAT. MY NAME IS THE BILL IN
TERMS OF WHAT STEP THE
DEPARTMENT IS IN IN RESPONSE AB
FIVE EIGHT TO MAKE SURE. ALL
PEOPLE IT IS A REGULAR
COMPLIANCE. AB FIVE KIND OF AN
INTERESTING- DYNAMIC WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BECAUSE DYNAMAX DECISION CAME
OUT THAT WAS ACTUALLY SOMETHING
THAT. SOME OF BOARDS BEIRUT.
EIGHTY FIVE WHEN IT WAS
ACTUALLY WRITTEN AND PASSED IT
ACTUALLY GAVE AN EXEMPTION TO
THOSE INDIVIDUAL BOARDS AND
GIRLS WHO WERE ACTUALLY- MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEXT
DECISION- HOWEVER WE STILL EVEN
THOUGH BECAUSE IT'S CLEAR WE
REALLY THAT'S NOT SUCH BOARD
HAS ARE YOU OVER BUT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT SEIZE WE- FROM OUR-
A LETTER. ME GET AND ARE LEGAL
TO THE BOROUGH'S DURING ONE.
AROUND SO THEY CAN THEN PASSED
INFORMATION ON TO THEIR
LICENSEES AND THEN WE'RE
DIRECTING THE VISUALS AGAIN
BACK TO THE APPROPRIATE PLEASE
THE- I CAN THINK OF IT RIGHT
NOW. ALL TODAY I'M SO THEY
ACTUALLY ANSWER THE ARE MY- I'M
WE DID ROLE SOME IN. AND WE
SOME INFORMATION. TIPS FOR HMO
BUT IT'S NOT UNDER OUR RESTORE
ABOUT WE DIRECTED THEM TO THEIR
PROBE ENTITY GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT IT SIR. THIS WE
ARE GOOD. TWO ONE TWO TWO IN
SUPPORT A REMINDER FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT VIA PHONE THE PURPOSE
OF TOLL FREE NUMBER IS ONE.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE FOUR IN THE CODE IS A-
FORTY FIVE. THREE FIFTY SIX AND
AGAIN IT'S AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCREEN AND I'LL GIVE THAT
NUMBER ONE MORE TIME FREE.
418-442-9163 SIXTY. AND THE TAX
CODE IS EIGHTY FORTY FIVE. THIS
IS HERE IN ROOM. THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
S. C. I. CALIFORNIA. RECTOR AND
WE TO APPRECIATE AND THANK HER
FOR HER THIRTY YEARS OF
CONSUMER SEARCH. OF CALIFORNIA.
ALL LOADED THE WATER VARIETY OF
THOSE SAID THERE SEVEN. OF
BOARDS IN BUREAUS I WOULD. NOTE
THAT IT THE- SPANS THE LIFE OF
SOMEONE BECAUSE THEY REGULAR
FROM MY NURSES. DOCTORS AT THE
FRONT END TO END FUNERAL
COMMITTEE YOU'VE BEEN. WORK
WITH THE DOCTOR AND TEAM UP. TO
FEW SHORT MONTHS AGO FOR A
THOUGH IT FEELS AN ATTORNEY ON
IN THAT MORE TO SIR ARE IN FACT
TO SAY STE AS IN THE STATE OF.
AND X. SINCE SO SURE THEY WILL
CAN TO. ARE THE HE HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND OPEN AND SO
WE APPRECIATE. THAT WE HAVE SO
FAR TO WORK WITH HER AND HOPE
TO DO FOR MANY YEARS IN THE SO
WITH THAT. YOUR COMP OF
DIRECTOR KURT MEYER THANK.
THANK YOU I CAN'T BELIEVE. YOU
KNOW. IS HERE BROOM WE- THANK
YOU ANYWAY ROOM ONE TWELVE TO
TESTIFY IN OF THE NATION OF
DIRECT KERR MAIER. C. NONE. WE
WILL NOW TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE OR THE MADAM
READER IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPERTY WILL BE TO IN SO OF
THE APPOINTMENT WE WILL. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE TO.
IN SO OF DIRECTOR KIRK FIGHTER
YOU WILL WANT ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD. AGAIN THAT
IS WHY. FAN ZERO ON YOUR-
KEYPAD. WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO WHAT. TWO THE LINE
IS A. YEAH RIGHT AFTER THE
AMERICAN OF WILL BE TO YOU
STILL AND CALIFORNIA AFTER
MEDICAL SO. SOLUTIONS ON FOR
THE COMPANY THE SCRIPT WE WILL
PORTABLE INTERNET SHE CAN. HOW
MANY I'M NOT A MODERATOR HOW
MANY PEOPLE DO WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT. LET ME DOUBLE
CHECK JUST A MOMENT- I AM
SHOWING ELEVEN OKAY GREAT WELL
LET'S PROCEED. HE WILL FORTY
SEVEN LINE FOUR SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN. FOR SURE IT FIRST MY
NAME IS GERRY HAS BEEN AND I AM
HONORED AND TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
THE DIRECTOR ON BEHALF OF THE-
AND- ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS BUT THE COMMITTEE
HAS CONFIRMED TODAY THE WEALTH
OF EXPERIENCE AND LEADERSHIP
DIRECTOR SHOW NUMBER. I THINK
IT'S OKAY LEADERSHIP AND DIRECT
AN OPEN DOOR POLICY AND
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND ALSO
PROVIDING FOR AN EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY- LICENSURE OF THE
PROFESSIONS AND WILL ALSO. BUT
THAT WE AGREED TO WORK IN TERMS
OF THE CEMETERY INDUSTRY IN
ADDRESSING THE ESSENTIAL WORK
ASPECT TO CALL THE NINETEEN
UNDER IN THIS CRITICAL PHASE SO
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT OUR
OPERATIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETEEN THAT IS LINE ONE NINE
HOW WITH THE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
THE PRESIDENT. FOR NEARLY STATE
THE DEPARTMENT WIRE
CONFIRMATION AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. YOU SEE OPERATE THE
LARGEST HEALTH SCIENCES
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM IN THE
NATION ENROLLING APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND HEALTH
SCIENCES. AND TRAINEES ACROSS
NINETEEN SCHOOL ON SEVEN
CAMPUSES. IT'S BEEN CRITICAL TO
DENTISTRY MEDICINE NURSING
OPTOMETRY PHARMACY PUBLIC
HEALTH AND VETERINARY MEDICINE.
YOU SEE HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATIVE OF KIRK MYERS
LEADERSHIP DURING THAT CALL BUT
CRISIS ENABLING OUR STUDENTS TO
CONTINUE TO LEARN AND BECOME
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. AND THE LETTER TO
THE COURT UNDER THE SIGNATURE
OF CATHERINE NATION THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF HEALTH SCIENCES
BUT THEN UC HEALTH. AND BOTH
SHE AND I HAVE ENJOYED WORKING
WITH KIRK MYERS AND THREE DAYS
THE MEDICAL BOARD. CALIFORNIA
VERY LUCKY LUCKY FOR HER
DEDICATION TO PUBLIC SERVICE
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
HER CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT TESTIMONY
I'D LIKE TO REMIND THOSE THAT
ARE TESTIFYING MAYBE KEEP IT
JUST A LITTLE A LITTLE BRIEFER.
THAT THE GREAT I'M NOT A
MODERATOR GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
ALTHOUGH TO LINE TWENTY THAT IS
LINE TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I MEDICARE AND SENATORS THIS IS
MATT BACK REPRESENTING THE
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
SCHOOLS WE'VE GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
DIRECTOR OVER THE LAST SO MANY
MONTHS TEN A GREAT JOB. INVID
KALENJIN TIMES. SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU HAS EXCELLENT
TESTIMONY. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTEEN THAT IS LINE
ONE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK THIS TACKY CAME OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AN EIGHT THE COURT APPOINTMENT
OF KIMBERLY CURTIS MEYER TO BE
DIRECTOR PTA IF YOU HEARD FROM
HER INTRODUCTION LEVEL
DISCUSSION KIRCH MEYER HAD.
ABILITY CONSUMER PROTECTION.
PERSPECTIVE WE'VE SPECIALLY
INCREASE HER AND WILL TO BIG
AND HER COMMITMENT TO PRACTICE
PROTECTING COULD THE CALIFORNIA
THEY ARE PATIENT THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU FOR TESTIFYING. AND WE
LIGHT- TWENTY THREE LINE TWO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CHRISTY UNDER WAY AND I
AM THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY AND ON BEHALF
TWENTY EIGHT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
THE- MANY COMMISSION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER. YEAH
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FORTY THAT IS LINE NUMBER FOUR
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OPERATES
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AMBULATORY SURGERY
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA'S
IDEA MANISTEE. OPEN STRONG
SUPPORT EMILY KIRK MYERS
APPOINTMENT AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
OF SKIP PAST ALL THE WONDERFUL
WORK WE'VE DONE WITH- OVER THE
YEARS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. BEING ADVOCATE
CONSUMER. IN THE WONDERFUL HE
GOES OUT OF HER WAY TO MAKE
SURE ALL STAKEHOLDERS INDIANS
ARE CONSIDERED. LASSEN TELL ME
FARM BUT BEAR IT'S YOU'RE DOING
GAUGE WITH MAYER THEREFORE
FIFTY THREE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
BEFORE OKAY ARE ENCOURAGED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR THANK YOU
COMPLEMENT OINTMENT THANK YOU
GARISH THANK YOU. FOR EACH. ONE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IMAGINE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA I THINK SURGEONS
THEM VERY HAPPY SUPPORT MISTER
COMPARISON PLYMOUTH AS THE
ACTOR DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS HAS ALREADY IN FEDERAL
TRADE PETER BUT I THINK WE
STAND UP MOST ARE FOR ME IS.
RESPECT NOT ALL. IT ONE I THINK
THAT I THINK ABOUT IN WILL DO
HER WELL AS SHE CONTINUES
FORWARD IN HER CAREER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU MAN.
YEAH MINE. LINE FOUR SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MERRY MCKENNA THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
NCTA. A CONFIRMATION OF MY
WORDS MY OUR TO THE BUSINESS
AFTER EASIER. SHE OUR EXPENSIVE
DAMAGE TO REGULATORY AND
OVERSIGHT SYSTEM AND HEALTH AND
IMPRESSED BY IN THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT HELD RELATION TO
ALREADY AND WE- PANDEMIC
LAWMAKERS MYERS CLEAR DIRECT
PERSPECTIVE WILL ACHIEVE GREAT
SUCCESS FORGET PLACE MOVIES AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE CONSUMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ATTORNEY
THE MANY OTHER REASONS WE'RE
PLEASED TO UNCONDITIONALLY
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION
INFORMATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FORTY
FIVE LINE FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER CALDERON WEAKNESS SO
SINCE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FUNERAL DIRECTORS
THE CALIFORNIA RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL HYGIENIST. AND WOULD
ONLY BE USED TO. YEAH THE CAR.
AFTER ACTOR KIRK BUT ALSO
WANTED THAT SHE BRINGS HER AN
EXTRAORDINARY SUPPORT STAFF
THAT REFLECTS LEADERSHIP AND
IT'S ALL RESPONSIVE AND HELPFUL
AND PORTAL. WE HOPE THAT. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MISSY JOHNSON IN THE OF THE
MARK FROM OUR CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AFTER.
TEN A CALIFORNIA THANK YEAH
FIFTY. THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGE MARRIAGE CONFIRMATION
AND WITH YOUR- MISTER CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO READ A BRIEF STATEMENT.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FARM
LOCATION AT STEVIA THAT SUIT
YEAH. ABSOLUTELY YEAH I HAVE
BEEN GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEADERSHIP THAT NEWS CAME COURT
TOMORROW OF THE DCA DURING THAT
CRISIS. AB H. A. AS AN
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
LICENSEES IN THE PROFESSION
APPRECIATES THE ABILITY. TO
OKAY THAT NO PERSON EIGHT YEAH
HAPPY TRADEMARK COMFORT
LEADERSHIP AT LEAST. TIME OF
INTENSITY SHE EXPECTED TO
ASSUME THAT DEL ROLE. ACROSS
THE WHOLE FROM OTHER
PROFESSIONS AND THE KEEPING
CALIFORNIA CAN SAVE. THE END OF
LIFE THE CONTAINING THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY. THE PAN. I PH
EVERY EVERY TIMELY WORK FOR
INCREASED ENROLLMENT. EVEN WHEN
OUR FOR WE COULD NOT BE
APPROVED UNDER HER LEADER WE
SELDOM OF THAT SIXTY FIVE FOR
PER. AND HEALTH HAVE I THINK.
UNDER IN FACT. ABOLITION OF
CULTURE RESPONSE AND PROBLEM
SOLVING BENEFIT THE
EFFECTIVENESS PROGRESS IN THE
CAP NINETEEN IS MAN THINGS AND
DC EIGHT EXCEPTION TODAY IN IN
THE YEARS COM CALLUM WILL NEED
LEADERSHIP. CREATE A PROFESSION.
THAT PANDEMIC IMPACT I AM CALM
DIRECTOR KERR MARGIN PROVIDE
THE WEEK. YEAH YOU. JOHN THANK
YOU WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT THAT IS LINE FOR EACH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE BACK ON
BEHALF OF CENTER A COUPLE.
REQUIRED THE MEDICAL OF HOW
WENT FURTHER THE TERM LIMITS ON
PROTECTION ALREADY BEEN ANY
OTHER DCA BOARD WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT SHE WOULD PUT
EXTRA CHEESE AND FOR CHANGE ALL
THE SHIPBOARD. THE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR YOU TOO IT TOOK
OF THAT DO WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE ON THE LINE. OPPONENTS.
YES LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT KURT TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS ONE. ZERO
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU MADAM GET
THIS POINT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
ANYONE HERE THAT IN THE
OPPOSITION YOU WILL BEGIN IN
THE THIRD. THANK YOU THERE TO
TESTIFY OPPOSITION. OUR
MODERATOR. YEAH THE MODERATOR
YOU CAN CHECK TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE. IN THE QUEUE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
APPOINTMENT. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TEST IT. OF THE APPOINTMENT OF
YOUR CAR BUYER YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YOU ARE IN A POSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YES NO
ONE QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO WE HEARD
FROM WITNESSES ANOTHER. FOR
FURTHER TO. SO WITH THAT IF.
THE D. S. SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FIVE
EIGHT AYE MONNING AYE MONNING
AYE ROTH IRAS ROTH AYE WILK HI
BOOK I ATKINS ON CALL GAVE
LOTUS- FOUR ZERO WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR HER FOR THE
M. SO THAT'S MORE THAN ENOUGH
SO. I BELIEVE WE'RE- WURSTER
STENOGRAPHERS CHYNNA TAKE A
BREAK IN THE ACTION SO WE WILL
BE BACK IN FIVE.
CENTER BATES
YEAH. WE'RE BACK IN MOTION
RIGHT. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
OUR NEXT APPOINTMENT WHICH IS-
MR LAND TODAY DAHLE SINI- JURIS
DOCTORATE DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION SO IF
YOU HAVE SO FROM LIKE YOUR
BACKGROUND SO IF YOU HAVE ONE
YOU LIKE TO INTRODUCE- WE WE'D
LOVE TO MEET THEM AND AT THAT
POINT. GO AHEAD AND IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS THANK YOU SIR.
YOU'RE THANK YOU FOR. THE TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY IF ONLY VIRTUALLY. MY
NAME IS VAL DAHLE SENIOR AND
I'M THE NOMINEE TO BECOME THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION. IT SHOULD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WITH YOUR
STAFF AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
TODAY'S CONVERSATION. AT THIS.
LIKE TO RETURN TO THE FRONT ROW
TO INTRODUCE MY FRIENDS AND
FAMILY BUT THAT WILL HAVE TO
WAIT FOR ANOTHER DAY. I WOULD
DO IN THE MEAN TIME. TO
INTRODUCE MY LEVEL ABSOLUTELY.
OUR MICHAEL MY FAMILY MY RUN
AND THEIR LOW SUPPORT AND IS
WITH ME EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
I WANT FINAL SOON PROP HERE. MY
DPRK EMILY IS ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. AND THIS
DEDICATED GROUP OF SCIENTISTS
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY EXPERTS
YIELD INSPECTORS RAM MANAGER
AND MANY UP. THE BILL PROGRAM
THAT PROTECTS HUMAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND TRULY
LEADS THE NATION IN DEVELOPING
SAFER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT TOOLS. AS DIRECTOR
IT'S BEEN MY PRIVILEGE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO LEARN FROM THEM
AND NOW TO LEAD THEM AS WE
COLLABORATE TOGETHER TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND THE PMR IS
THE- EXPERTISE HELLO HELLO.
LIKE EVERY OTHER DEPARTMENT OF
GOVERNMENT WE AT DPR HAVE SPENT
A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME
REIMAGINING THE WE PERFORM OUR
WORK. WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
TELEWORK STRATEGIES THAT
MINIMIZE EXTENDED FACE TO FACE
CONTACT. THE DOCTOR THE USE OF
VIRTUAL PLATFORMS LIKE THIS ONE
TO CONDUCT MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'VE ALSO
INSTITUTED REGULAR CHECK INS
WITH ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES. I'VE
MAINTAINED REGULAR CONTACT WITH
CPR'S FOUR HUNDRED OR SO
EMPLOYEES THROUGH EMAIL
TELECONFERENCES ZOOM MEETINGS
AND THE OCCASIONAL IPHONE VIDEO
MESSAGE. THERE'S NO QUESTIN
THAT THESE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGING TIMES BUT WE MOSTLY
MET THE MOMENT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S WORDS AND I'LL
CONTINUE TO PLAN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S. PROACT LI. LI
PORTAL PERMISSION. FINE SIR ALL
STATE THE ALL AND PASSED ASIDE
PUBLIC IS VERY CHALLENGING WORK
IT'S EMOTIONAL POLITICAL
TECHNICAL AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL WE GET IT RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME. YOU HAVE MANY
IMPORT ISSUES ON OUR B. R. THAT
I'M THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THE
JOB. MY GOAL IS TO THE DIRECTOR
NAY. BUT CHIEF AMONG THEM IS TO
CONTINUE STRENGTHENING DVRS
NATIONAL REPRESENT REP. AND AS
A LEADER. IN STEPHEN
SESTANOVICH. LYING ON THE
SCIENCE ORGANIZATIONAL
EXCELLENCE A WELL TRAINED AND
HIGHLY ENGAGED WORKFORCE.
COLLABORATIVE ENGAGEMENT WITH
ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND BY
BUILDING A CULTURE OF DPR
THAT'S OPEN TRANSPARENT AND
LASER FOCUSED ON THE FUTURE OF
PEST MANAGEMENT IN OUR GREAT.
ON SOME DAYS THE BULLS ARE
EASIER PUBLISHED OTHERS. BUT
DPR IS A CAN DO AGENCY AND
WE'RE DOING VITALLY IMPORTANT
THINGS EVERY DAY FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA TO TACKLE THE
ISSUE FACED. AND SEE
COMMONSENSE PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS
THAT WORK FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANKS AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DIRECTOR
DAHLE SINI AND I LET ME THINK
MY VICE CHAIRMAN FOR A- FORD.
IN COURT JOB AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES. WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO- MEMBERS FIRST AND THEN
MONEY LET ME START WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN. JACK
DAHLE SINI LET ME START BY BOTH
CONGRATULATING YOU ON THIS
APPOINTMENT BUT ALSO THANKING
YOU FOR YOUR CAREER OF PUBLIC
SERVICE YOU'VE SERVED
CALIFORNIA AND YOU'VE SERVED
OUR NATION IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WHEN WE SPOKE ON
THE PHONE I THINK MINDED. THE
RIGHT TIME AND I THINK YOU'RE
OVERVIEW ALSO CAPTURED THE MANY
DIFFERENT INTEREST GROUPS IN
DIFFERENT INTERESTS THAN IN
TIMES OF EMOTIONAL IN THE
MOMENT. BUT IN AMONG VARIOUS
INTEREST GROUPS. WE DID HAVE A
GOOD PHONE CONVERSATION ONE
AREA OF INTEREST YOU KNOW OF
MINE AND I THINK WOULD BE OF
INTEREST TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
WORK OF THE CLERK FOST
WORKGROUP CHLORPYRIFOS. THE
SITE AND IT'S BEEN PROVEN TO
HAVE POTENTIAL NEUROTOXIC IMPAX.
THE MOVEMENT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CANCEL ITS
REGISTRATION BUT I KNOW THAT'S
BEEN PART OF A PROCESS AND
WOULD APPRECIATE. AND OF THE
UPDATE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
CHLORPYRIFOS WORKGROUP AND HOW
THE PHASE OUT IS. NG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW I REALLY
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING WHEN I
CAME TO THE YOUR ABOUT A YEAR
AGO AND- STILL. REGISTRATION
AND BEGAN TO TAKE THE SECOND
STEP WAS TO CHARTER A WORKGROUP
WHICH WAS ASKED TO IDENTIFY
ALTERNATIVES TO CHLORPYRIFOS AS
WE FACED THAT OUT. WORKGROUP
MET THE NUMBER OF TIMES A THE
COURSE OF LAST FALL AND A VERY
ABBREVIATED PERIOD OF TIME IN
WHICH TO DO ITS WORK. BUT IT
WAS A GREAT IN THE FIRST.
STAKEHOLDER REPRESENTING IBM
EXPERTS ACADEMICS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS FARMWORKER
HEALTH. REPRESENTATIVES PCA'S
AND OTHERS WHO WERE REALLY ABLE
TO HELP CRYSTALLIZE THE
CONVERSATION AND FOCUS ON THE
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO. THE
WORLD BEYOND US. THE ULTIMATE
REPORT WHICH WE ISSUED A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO IDENTIFIED SOME
SYNTHETIC CHEMIST TREES THAT
ACOSTA SIDES ESSENTIALLY. THAT
COULD ACT AS ALTERNATIVES BUT
ALSO A PESTICIDES. GROUP
FURTHER ECOMMENDED THAT
ADDITIONAL. BEING MADE IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S IBM
WORK I THINK THAT THAT'S
ESSENTIAL AND FINALLY THE
WORKGROUP COMMANDED THAT WE
CHARTER A SECOND SUCCESSOR
WORKGROUP TO LOOK AT THE
BROADER SYSTEM WIDE ISSUES
AROUND THE TRADE MISSION TO
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT.
AND SO WELL THE WORKGROUPS
FOCUSED SMOKING IT OR PURIFY US
AND WHAT WE CAN DO IN THE NEAR
TERM IT ALSO LOOKS MORE BROADLY.
SINCE THE IS THAT WE CAN DO THE
FOCUS ON CONSISTING OF A
MANAGEMENT THE EFFORTS OF THAT
SET WORK WILL BEGIN IN THE FALL
AND IT WILL HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN. OR SO. DO ITS AND I
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO DIGGING
INTO THOSE ISSUES WHICH WILL
RUN THE GAMUT FROM. IBM TO
HEALTHY SOILS TO CLEAN AIR AND
WATER TO BYSTANDER AND WORKER
HEALTH. REALLY THE- ENTIRE
SPECTRUM OF ISSUES THAT FACE US
WHETHER YOUR FARMING OR WHETHER
YOU'VE GOT A BACKYARD GARDEN
THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
MANAGING CUSTOMER. THANK YOU
FOR THAT IN. RENTS TOP PM. THE
PAST. AS WE JUST. IT'S A PART
OF THE- VERNACULAR IF YOU IN
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY EVERYONE
A SUPPORTER OF INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT BUT IT DOES MEAN
DIFFERENT THINGS TO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND I THINK. FIFTEEN
KIND OF TO THE ENFORCEMENT SIDE
OF YOUR PORTFOLIO COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONERS ARE CHARGED WITH
ENFORCEMENT OF OUR STATE
PESTICIDE LAWS FEDERAL AND
STATE IN SOME AREAS THE STATE
HAS. LEGISLATED OR IMPLEMENTED.
THE HIGHER STANDARDS IF YOU
WILL ARE MORE STRICT STANDARDS
THAN THE FEDERAL STANDARDS AND
SO MY QUESTION GOES TO THAT AND
FORCE MEANT RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN YOUR OFFICE AND THE
COUNTY AG COMMISSIONERS AND
PARTICULARLY NOW WITH COVERT
NINETEEN. AND SO MANY WORK IN
IN FOR AGE. WERE FOR HOME THEIR
OWN SAFETY AND HEALTH AND
PROTECTION. HOW DOES THE
ENFORCEMENT THE ROLE OF YOUR
OFFICE AND OF COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONERS WITH FARMWORKERS
CONSIDERED AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
CONTINUING TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS WHILE OTHERS ARE MAY BE
ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME. HOW
DOES THE IN FORCE OF THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS. MOVE FORWARD WITH
BOTH SAFETY OF ENFORCEMENT
WORKERS BUT ALSO SAFETY FOR
FARMWORKERS PESTICIDE
APPLICATORS OTHER AGRICULTURAL
THIS. THOSE ARE GREAT QUESTIONS
SENATOR AND I'LL START BY
SAYING THAT I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT
ABATED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. WE
WENT. AND LIKE THE OTHER
DIRECTORS BEFORE ME HAVE
ARTICULATED WHERE WE WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BEST. DO OUR WORK AND FULFILL
OUR MISSION BUT REALLY THE
ENFORCEMENT WORK THAT WE DO
WHETHER IT'S INSPECTING.
PRODUCE AT WHOLESALE MARKETS
FOR PESTICIDE RESIDUE OR GOING
OUT TO INVESTIGATE PESTICIDE
INCIDENTS WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN
A MISTAKE USE. INSTANT HAVE
HAVE CONTINUED. A FULL THROTTLE
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE AG
COMMISSIONERS OF CALIFORNIA IS
A VERY COMPLIMENTARY ONE. AND
THE FACT IS THEY DO A LOT OF
ENFORCEMENT WORK ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S BEHALF IN THE
FIELD AND EVERY COUNTY UP AND
DOWN THE STATE FROM. OREGON TO
THE MEXICAN BORDER AND SO
THAT'LL WORK DURING THIS
PANDEMIC HAS ALSO CONTINUES. OF
QUITE ENERGETICALLY AND QUITE
VIGOROUSLY WE HAVE OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST NUMBER OF
MONTHS ISSUED SEVERAL GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS THAT. FOCUS ON THE
TASK AT HAND AND I THINK THAT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE'RE THE
GREATEST RESPIRATORY HEALTH.
CRISIS THAT THE WORLD IS IN FOR
A HUNDRED YEARS IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT COMMISSIONERS AS WELL AS
DPR STAFF ANOTHER REGULAR. ONE
MOST RESPONSE. ARE AND HOW
VIDEO. THE RULES THAT OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS HAVE AS WELL. SO I
THINK THAT THE ENFORCEMENT WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE HAS CONTINUED.
WE REALLY HAVEN'T MISSED A BEAT
IN THAT REGARD AND I'M VERY
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE. WITH REGARD TO
WORKER HEALTH WE'VE WORKED WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO.
PERIODICALLY SURVEY ARE AG
COMMISSIONERS TO DETERMINE WHAT
THEIR P. P. ET. PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
REQUIREMENTS ARE IN A GIVEN
COUNTY. AND TO ENSURE THAT
GIVEN THE AG WORKERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. THAT THEY
HAVE A PROPER ACCESS TO PPP
WHETHER IT'S TIED BACK. SUITS
FOR PESTICIDE APPLICATORS OR N.
NINETY FIVE MASKS OR OTHER
THINGS. FACE SHIELDS GOGGLES
AND THE LIKE. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT MY EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE GOING OUT TO DO
INSPECTIONS AND TO DO THEIR OWN
ENFORCEMENT WORK HAVE ACCESS.
TO THAT ALL ESSENTIAL PP AS
WELL. BUT WE REALLY DON'T IN
PARTNERSHIP AS DPR HAS FOR THE
LAST NUMBER OF DECADES. WITH
THE AG COMMISSIONERS ARE ARE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM IS. VERY
SOLID AND I'M PLEASED THAT- YOU
KNOW IN SUCH A WONDERFUL
PARTNER FOR US. WE'RE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS. MAKE THE CHIP. OTHER
LEADERS TRANSITION RECENTLY AND
SO BEEN. AND AGAIN OUT TO THE-
AND MEETING WITH COMMISSIONERS
WHAT I CAN AND- LEARNING FROM
THEM DIRECTLY IN THEIR TEENS
HOW WE CAN HELP AND HOW WE CAN.
PROVIDE MORE ASSISTANCE TO THE
ACT. BUT WE REALLY CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON. THAT AND FOR WORK
WHAT IS A REAL PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL IT
SHOULD BE. KELLY P. A. AT
THROUGHOUT THE GOVERNMENT SO.
REGULATORY PROGRAMS WITH
REGARDS ASTROCYTE PROTECTIONS
ARE ENFORCED AND ENFORCED
VIGOROUSLY AND I'M PLEASED TO
SAY THAT THEY ARE BEING. THANK
YOU AND THEN MY- A LITTLE
FURTHER ON THE ENFORCEMENT AS
WE DISCUSSED THE AREA I
REPRESENT. MONTEREY COUNTY
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY THERE'S BEEN
SOME INNOVATIVE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN COMMUNITY- AND THE AG
COMMISSIONER IN AGRICULTURE
SAFE SCHOOLS SAFE AG- THE
MONTEREY COUNTY AG COMMISSIONER
IN CANADA NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
WENT BEYOND REQUIREMENTS OF THE
REGULAR FILING OF THIS OF
INTENT AND THEN AFTER THE
APPLICATION I USE REPORT. WITH
DIRECT COMMUNICATION WITH
SCHOOL PERSONNEL- TEACHER
GROUPS REST FAMILIES LIVING
NEAR SCHOOL SITES. TO BETTER
COURTNEY NOTICE AND APPLICATION
PERIOD SWIM SCHOOL SITES ARE
VACANT AND ALSO IN ANTICIPATION
OF CHILDREN COMING BACK TO THE
SCHOOL SITES. JUST BRIEFLY
COMMENT ON THAT PROGRAM AND
COULD THAT BE A MODEL THAT
COULD BE REPLICATED- IN OTHER
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION CENTER MONEY I
THINKIT'S A GREAT PILOT
PROGRAM YOU KNOW IT'S STILL
JUST TWO OR THREE YEARS OLD SO
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE OUTRAGE THAT
WE DO AROUND A PROGRAM LIKE
THAT REACHES ALL OF THE FOLKS
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT IT SHOULD
BUT I THINK THAT REPRESENTS.
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY BUILD UPON TO
ESTABLISH A BROADER STATEWIDE
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM IN FACT I'M
ON MY WAY TO THE SENATE ALLEY
LATER IN THE TO HAVE SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS WITH. REST AND
SEVEN YOUR REP AND OTHERS OUT
THERE TO SEE IF WE COULD BEGIN
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION AROUND
WHAT NOTIFICATION COULD LOOK
LIKE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
I THINK THAT- YOU KNOW THAT'S
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES THAT COME TO MY DE SINCE
I'M- SORRY LAST FOURTEEN MONTHS
OR SO AND IT'S REALLY WANT TO
TRY. PEOPLE OTHER. HELLO TRUST
COMES TO. ATIONS THAT AND I
THINK THE OF WHAT'S IN THE
VALLEY IS THAT YOU KNOW THE CAN
HAS REALLY BEEN A TO BE A LOT
OF DESPERATE TO GATHER. HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
NOTIFICATION COULD LOOK LIKE
AND ONE OF THE CATION MAY LOOK
LIKE- IN THE MORE STATEWIDE
APPLICATION THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND JUST MY FINAL COMMENT ON
THAT I AGREE I THINK. SOFTEN
RESISTANCE. SOME RESISTANCE OF
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT
REGULATION CONTROLS AND YET.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FIELD
POSTING BACK IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES RESULTED IN A
REDUCTION OF CREW POISONINGS
FROM DRAFT AND THEN
CONSEQUENTLY REDUCTION IN
LIABILITY IN SIMILARLY I THINK
THIS NOTIFICATION PROGRAM IN
THE PONDERA VALLEY. ALLENS
VOLUNTARY- AS A MODEL. IT'S A
WIN WIN FOR THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE IT SERVES THE
PURPOSE OF TRANSPARENCY SHARING
OF INFORMATION AND THE ULTIMATE
GOAL TO REDUCE ACCIDENTS IN. ON
NECESSARY UNWANTED EXPOSURES
AND THAT LEADS TO LIMITED
LIABILITY SO I HOPE. YOU WILL
BE A CHAMPION OF THAT STATEWIDE
IN AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU THAT WAS A GREAT
DISCUSSION SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU OF MADAM PROTEON WELCOME
BACK THANK YOU- CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR APPOINTMENT- DIRECTOR
THE LITHUANIA AND JOBS GREAT
GREAT BACKGROUND OF BIG JOB
AHEAD BECAUSE THIS IS AN AREA
THAT HAVE A LOT OF CONTROVERSY
AND AN UNDERSTATED PROBABLY.
ABOUT I AM VERY INTERESTED IN
THE RESEARCH GRANT PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN FUNDED TO SEEK THE
ALTERNATIVES TO PESTICIDES THAT
DO BECOME BANNED AND CERTAINLY-
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR FAMILY
MEMBER A BELOVED FAMILY MEMBER-
ON MANY YEARS AGO ACTUALLY
HAPPENED TIMELY DOWN. DUE TO
EXPOSURE OF PESTICIDE AT THAT
TIME AND I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER
THE NAME OF IT WILL BAN MANY
YEARS BUT. I THINK PHONE BILL
IMPORT BUT I THINK OF WE ALL
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE THEM.
WE HAVE TO CONTROL IN SO MORE
DISEASE AND DOC SO IT'S A
PUBLIC SAFETY OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE THAT NEEDS BALLOTS
CLEARLY AND I THINK THAT THAT.
THE OUR RESEARCH GRANT PROGRAM
TO SEEK OUT THROUGH SCIENCE AND
DATA FROM ALTERNATIVES OF A
REALLY GREAT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IT COULD YOU UPDATE
ON FOUND OUT IN AND- IS IT IS
IT WORKING OUT. YOU KNOW WHAT
TO. SENATOR THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION AND I'M SORRY TO HEAR
ABOUT YOUR AMILY MEMBER- I
THINK THAT IN MY TIME AT THE PR
MY CONVERSATIONS WITH THOSE
THAT IT MINISTER OUR GRANTS
PROGRAM HAVE BEEN VERY. YOU
KNOW FRUITFUL FOR ME TO LEARN
ABOUT THE SUCCESSES. OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WE RUN FOR THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS. WE DO A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT GRANT
PROGRAMS SOMETHING CALLED
ALLIANCE. PROGRAM FOCUSES MORE
ON. COMMUNITY BASED AND I
SUPPOSE NON ACADEMIC EFFORTS
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME
ACADEMICIANS THAT APPLIED AND
RECEIVED THOSE GRANTS. AND THEN
THERE ARE OUR BASIC RESEARCH
GRANTS WHICH WE- PROVIDE TO ACT
MAKES MANY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR TO ALL.
TO EGGMAN TO VETERANS. THE MORE
APPROPRIATE WAYS TO CERTAIN HAS
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO MAKE IN
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SCIENCE BEHIND PESTICIDES IN
OUR EVOLUTION FRANKLY FROM
RELIANCE ON THE HARDER
INDUSTRIES TO LOOKING FOR THE
ALTERNATIVES THAT YOU MENTIONED
PERHAPS THE GREENER PERHAPS THE
SOFTER CHEMISTRIES INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT APPROACH IS
THAT THE I THINK THAT WORK
GROUP THAT I REFERENCED AT THE
TOP OF MY REMARKS WILL WILL
FULLY COVER. SO PART OF WHAT
YEAR'S BUDGET ON THE ONE.
APPROVAL OF THAT UP A SET
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO DO CORPORATE
COST PACIFIC GRANT RELATED WORK
AND CDFA HAD A PIECE OF THAT AS
WELL AND- WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF BUILDING THOSE GRANTS AND I
THINK THAT. ALSO HELPS INDUSTRY
WHICH HAD RELIED FOR MANY YEARS
ON FOR YOUR OF US THE BROAD
SPECTRUM PESTICIDE USED. ON
ABOUT SIXTY DIFFERENT APPS FROM
ALL. IT WAS EXPENSIVE IT WAS
VERY FACT AND A RESULT IT WAS
USED BY WIDELY. BUT WE REALLY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WELL WE WERE GOING THIS
PROCESS. PARKER FOSTER GRATION.
THAT WE WEREN'T SIMPLY PULLING
THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER. ARMORS
ANOTHER COMMODITY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT USE. OR PURIFY US BUT
INSTEAD WE'RE PROVIDING SOME
MONEY TO DO RESEARCH INTO
ALTERNATIVES. YOU KNOW YOU MADE
A GREAT POINT ABOUT THE OF. THE
FACT THAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO FIND A BALANCE HERE. I THINK
I FOUND SOME TOP JOBS IN MY
TIME BUT BEING THE DIRECTOR OF
EPR IS CERTAINLY. HIGH AMONG
THEM BECAUSE YOU'RE ALWAYS.
UNDER THE MICROSCOPE AND THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING HERE DPR
IS ALWAYS IN THE CROSS HAIRS
FOR. ONE GROUP TO ANOTHER AND
SO SEEKING THAT BALANCE
BETWEEN. PROVIDING APPROPRIATE.
CROP PROTECTION TOOLS TO THE
THREE THAT SUPPORTS IT. AND ALL.
THE COMPANY IN CORNIA AND ALSO
TOWARDS THE FUTURE. A FEW MANY
CAL WANT TO SHARE AND THAT'S
USING SAY AND MORE SAYS. S.
MANAGEMENT TOOL IS ALSO IN FOR
AND THAT'S FINE LINE IS- YOU
KNOW THE LINE THAT WE WALK
AROUND HERE BUT I THINK WE DO
IT SUCCESSFULLY. WOULD VERY AND
VERY OFTEN AGING FINE NO IT'S
ON THE IT'S A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE LIKE THE
RODENTICIDES YOU KNOW WE'RE
STILL. GET O MIRED IN DOUBT
AND CERTAINLY ON BOTH SIDES OF
THAT THERE'S A THREAT TO OUR-
CERTAINLY HUMANKIND AND ANIMAL
KIND AND- THAT THAT ONE'S GOING
TO. YOU KNOW BE VERY EXCITING I
THINK GOING FORWARD BUT I KNOW
THAT IF WE'VE GOT THE FUNDS TO
BE LOOKING FOR THOSE THINGS
THAT WILL HELP US. YOU KNOW
CONTROL. AND PROTECT IN TIME
REALLY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE
AND STEPPING INTO THIS
EXTREMELY. IN FINANCE. MY
SERVER. BUT TO VOTE THANK YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOU SENATOR
BATES VICE. THANK YOU ARE PRO.
SERVICES SAID SOMETHING THAT
WAS INTERESTING TO ME HE SAID
EVERYBODY SUPPORTS IT GRATED
PAST MANAGEMENT BUT IT MEANS
DIFFERENT THINGS TO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE SO IN THAT CONTEXT IN
TERMS OF CROP PROTECTION AS A
PROPERTY SHOULDN'T TOOL. WHAT
THE STATE WILL MEAN TO YOU.
WELL I THINK THAT EXISTENCE-
PAST MANAGEMENT OR INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT AND TO MY MIND
SENATOR WILL THE TWO ARE
SOMEWHAT INTERCHANGEABLE TERMS
MEANS THIS IT MEANS LESS OF A
RELIANCE ON THE SYNTHETIC
PESTICIDES THAT PREVIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN THE GO TO FOR MOST LARGE
SCALE AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS.
EXAMPLE I TWO HIM TO A WINERY
NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE LAST YEAR
IN CENTER IN COUNTY THAT WILL
PROFIT OF ARSENIC WASPS IT INTO
THE VINEYARDS IN ORDER TO GO
AFTER TESTS THERE NOW THEY
COULD HAVE SPRAYED THE COULD
HAVE TESTED NEGATIVE ON ANY
NUMBER OF THINGS YOU WANT TO
TRY SO. A LITTLE FRIEND TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. THANK UP ALL
DIFFERENT TACK TO AVOID AN OVER
RELIANCE ON THINGS LIKE WORKER
FUSS AND OTHER HARDER CHEMICAL
SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU INCORPORATE A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO
MANAGING PASSED AND I WOULD SAY
THAT IN THE I. P. TOOL BOX
THERE IS A PLACE FOR. SYNTHETIC
PESTICIDES AND THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE BUT YOU CAN
START WITH THINGS THAT DON'T
HAVE QUITE THE POTENTIAL FOR.
THREE TO EITHER. WELL PRICED.
OR AND BY HEALTH GENERALLY. I
THE CONTEXT OF BACKYARD
GARDENER AND THAT'S ALSO AN
IMPORTANT. WORLD FOR DPR. WE'VE
PRODUCED ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
I PM RESOURCES FOR BACKYARD
GARDENERS TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT
MORE HOW. RELY LESS THINGS LIKE
LIFE IS. SAMPLE PLANTING NATIVE
SPECIES OR SIMPLY OUT WITH. A
TRIAL AND DOING SOME HAND
WEEDING THERE ARE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT YOU CAN
INCORPORATE IBM INTO THE WORK
DO AROUND YOUR HOUSE IN THE
BACKYARD OR ON THE BACK FORTY.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE MY AGE. AS
DIRECTOR OF. A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS BUT I REALLY THINK OF IT
AS THE- IN A PERHAPS THE
BIGGEST AND MOST IMPORTANT OF
MY GOALS IS TO REALLY BOTH
REDUCE RISK PEST MANAGEMENT.
AND PROMOTE THIS CONCEPT OF
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT OR
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT. AS
A WAY TO HELP. CALIFORNIANS
TRANSITION AWAY FROM. CHEMICALS
AND MORE THANK THAT. BUT
LIGHTER TOUCH. GREAT I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER AND I
LOOK TO VOTING FOR YOUR
NOMINATION WHEN SENATOR ROTH
MAKES IT. THANK YOU SIR I KNOW
THERE MIGHT BE COMPETITION
HERE- SENATOR ROTH HUMANA PRO
TEMS DIRECTOR CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M PRIVILEGED TO
REPRESENT TO INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND OR PORTIONS OF
IT AND- SEVERAL OF MY FRIENDS-
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS OF-
FOR YEARS BEEN ENGAGED IN
CITRUS FARMING AND- CITRUS
MANAGEMENT NOW THEY'RE ALSO
ENGAGED UP IN THE- CENTRAL
VALLEY IS THAT INDUSTRY IS
MIGRATED NORTH. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT OF COURSE THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND OF COURSE
THEN I AM CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THIS ASIAN CITRUS PSYLLID THIS
WOMAN BEING. BUSY IN THE BILL
IMPACT THAT THAT. THAT IT CAN
HAVE ON OUR MAJOR CITRUS
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE SINCE
FLORIDA'S INDUSTRY AS I
UNDERSTAND IT HAS BEEN. THEY DO
YOU THINK WE HAVE DONE ENOUGH
AS A STATE AND WE'VE DEVOTED
ENOUGH MONEY TO COMBATING THIS
OF LONG LONG BEING. HLB DISEASE
AND IF NOT WHAT CAN WE DO. US
SENATOR WELL THAT'S A GREAT A
PARDON ME CENTER RIGHT THAT'S
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE HAVE FRANKLY I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE COULD EVER
DEVOTE ENOUGH MONEY TO THE KIND
OF RESEARCH THAT WOULD ADDRESS.
ACPYOU KNOW CITRUS IN
CALIFORNIA'S A SEVEN OR EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY IT'S
REALLY AN ESSENTIAL PART OF THE
OVERALL HEALTH OF OUR AG
ECONOMY AND SO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE- ADDRESSING CITRUS
GREENING AND DEVOTING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO AND
MY COLLEAGUES AT CDFA HAVE DONE
REALLY FAR MORE WORK THAN.
WE'VE DONE HERE EPR AROUND THE
ASIAN CITRUS PSYLLID IN THE
BEST WAY TO CONTAIN IT. AND
RESEARCH IS YOU KNOW STILL
ONGOING I THINK THERE ARE SOME
PROMISING DEVELOPMENTS A
PARTICULARLY OUT OF UC
RIVERSIDE AS YOU WELL KNOW
RIGHT THERE ARE SOME PROMISING
DEVELOPMENTS IN FLORIDA AND
TEXAS AS WELL AND YOU KNOW THE
STATE'S ALREADY. HAD THE
RAVAGES OF THE CITRUS FOR THE
IMPACT THEIR INDUSTRY BUT WE
REALLY YOU KNOW GOT TO BE ON
TOP OF THAT BEFORE IT GOES FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REALLY IN.
OF THE CITRUS BELT IN TULARE
AND KERN AND FRESNO COUNTIES IN
EARNEST AND I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE SUPPORT LETTERS
THAT I WAS THE PROUDEST
RECEIVED WAS FROM CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK AND I WORK WITH
CENTRIST USUALLY YEARS ON. YOU
KNOW ENSURING THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO YOU KNOW FIND THAT BALANCE
THAT I MENTIONED TO THE SENATOR
WELL I THINK THAT THERE'S MORE
THAT WE CAN DO WHEN THERE'S ALL
THESE CONTINUING WORK- WITH.
GOING FORWARD SURE. WATSON I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ATTENTION TO THIS VERY VERY.
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING YOUR
CONFIRMATION SIR
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
CENTER ON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DIRECTOR WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GO NOW TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I APPRECIATE
THE DIALOGUE I THINK IT'S BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL FOR US AND A
VERY IMPRESSIVE- YOUR RESUME-
IN ADDITION TO- TO EVERYTHING
YOU SHARED WIT US TODAY I
THINK- IT BODES WELL- CERTAINLY
THIS APPOINTMENT SO- THANK YOU-
I'LL MAKE A COMMENT BEFORE A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WHO WANT
TO JOIN THE COMMENT VIA PHONE.
WHICH WILL HAPPEN IN A FEW
MINUTES THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHT ZERO FOUR FIVE THREE FIVE
SIX. NUMBER AGAIN. 844-291-6364
ACCESS CODE EIGHT ZERO FOUR
FIVE THREE FIVE SIX. SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH WITH HIS IN
HERE THREE THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. OF YOU KNOW THE DRILL LET
ME SAY WELCOME- GO AHEAD. AND
FIGURE OUT I'M SURE MEMBERS
CHRISTIAN CALIAN IF YOU'LL
INDULGE ME MADAM CHAIR ON THIS
AND ANOTHER FOR THIRTY SECONDS.
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING
VALPO SINI HAVING WORKED WITH
HIM AND BEATING BEEN A FRIEND
FOR TWENTY YEARS SO I WANTED
TO. URGE YOUR CONFIRMATION YOU
KNOW WE'RE A MANY OF YOU HAVE A
COMMENTED ON HIS COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK WITH HIM IN BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL POSITIONS THAT HE'S
HAD PARTICULARLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND HE HAS
DEDICATED HIS LIFE HIS ADULT
LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND TO
THE AGRICULTURE SECTOR. I WAS
SO PLEASED WHEN HE RETURNED
FROM HIS TENURE. I WORK FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IN WASH DC TO
COME BACK TO SACRAMENTO AND
CONTINUE HIS PUBLIC SERVICE AND
SO I PROJECTS. THANK YOU MATT.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO OF WITNESSES AND
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I'M GOING
TO GO TO WAR ROOM ONE TWELVE
JUST TO MAKE SURE. WE LOVE
SEEING THAT PICTURE OF ROOM ONE
TWELVE. AND SEEING NO ONE THERE
WERE GOING TO NOW MOVED TO ODD-
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
MODERATOR IN THE WINGS WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
TO TESTIFY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR
DAHLE SINI YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. OF
DIRECTOR DAHLE SINI YOU WILL
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE BLIND
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JAMES TALENT BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
I'M NOT. WE HAD DIRECTOR DAHLE
YOU NEED DURING HIS TIME IN
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT. HOW
THEY CAN- IMPROVE THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AND PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH HIM ON THAT ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN THAT IS LINE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE
GO AHEAD- ACTUALLY LOOK THAT
LINE DISCONNECTED LET'S GO TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE THAT IS
LINE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARGARET REDUCE SENIOR
SCIENTIST TESTIFIED ACTION
NETWORK AND ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OR COALITION CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM
REPRESENTING ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE-
MOSTLY- PESTICIDE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SH- THE CONTRIBUTION OF
MR DOSIMETERS POSITIONS WE HAVE
WORKERS FROM CREDITORS I WAS A
MEMBER OF. TAX COLLECTOR SHOWS.
FURNITURE'S WORKGROUP. FIRST
RECALL THAT WAS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE SUBJECT WORKER
THAT CELL MENTIONED WELL YOU
VERY REGARD HAVE A STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
THAT IS LINE FIVE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. COMPLAIN OF FIFTY
FOUR WE DO HAVE THE LINE OPEN
YOU MAY WANT TO CHECK YOUR
MUTE. FUNCTION WE DO HAVE A
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. NINE FIFTY
FOUR. I JUST MOMENT LET ME TRY
THAT AGAIN. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY FOUR LINE FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS- NEED TO CONFIRM
BALBOA P. AS THE PR DIRECTOR.
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED ABOUT OVER
THE MANY YEARS THAT THE
RESPONSE AND CANDID IN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FOR
AGRICULTURE AND THE ENVIRONMENT
BUT OPPOSED BY PESTICIDE USE IN
THE NEED TO PRIORITIZE PURSUIT
OF INNOVATIVE AND SUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
THAT BETTER PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY PROMOTE ECOLOGICAL
SERVICES. AND ADDRESS AND
REDUCE ADVERSE FARMWORKER IN
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPACTS
BECAUSE OF HIS DEEP EXPERIENCE
AND DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
OUR SHARED GOAL AND HAVE THE
CREDIBILITY TO CALIFORNIA
FAMILY FARMERS CATHOLIC THE
CLICK IS VERY CLEAR THAT THE
PART ABOUT CONFIRMATION AS
DIRECTOR OF DPR AND- AS A POINT
OF NEIGHBORHOOD PRIDE. I JUST
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE WHAT A GREAT
NEIGHBOR VALLEY HIS WIFE ARE
AND METAFICTION YOU'LL
APPRECIATE THAT THEY WALK THEIR
ADORABLE DOG EVERY DAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND YOU FOR A MINUTE
HEARING TO TELL ME WHAT KIND OF
DOG THAT THAT IS BUT WILL GO TO
THE NEXT. IT'S. EVERYBODY AT
LEAST IN THE TRUNK REPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF BALBOA. AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
PENSIONS AND REGULATIONS HE
STARTED SERVING AS ACTING
DIRECTOR IN JUNE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUT HE REALLY HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING AND BRING MUCH
NEEDED STABILITY KERR
DEPARTMENT. DIRECTOR DOCKING
EXCELLED AT WORKING WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE STAKEHOLDERS AND
FINDING COMMON GROUND WHEN IT
IS MOST NEEDED AND THAT IS
ALMOST ALWAYS. A DPR. MAJOR
CONSERVANCY AS WELL I'M IN THE
RIGHT PATH PASSED THE
PARTICULAR USER. STATE NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AT USDA.
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY TO CONFIRM BALBOA
THEATRE DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT S. OKAY
MY NUMBER SIXTY TWO LINE SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB MARC
HERE ABOUT. OF CONTROL UP
CALIFORNIA. ORGAN OF REPRESENTS
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE LIVE CLOSE
FOR THE APPOINTMENT AND
CONFIRMATION BUT I'LL GO WITH
YOU TO THE POSITION OF DIRECTOR
OF DPR. LIKE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS YOU COULD.
PROBABLY WORK WITH THEM
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS. MANY
DIFFERENT THE AND STATE FEDERAL.
NEVER WALK AWAY AND- BADLY
ABOUT THE OUTCOME EVEN WHEN WE
DIDN'T LIKE ALSO WE REALLY
SUPPORT HIM ACCORDING WORKING
WITH IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU WE MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE THAT IS LINE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS BUSINESS
ANGEL GARCIA TODAY YOUR WITH
COALITION ADVOCATING FOR
PROSPECT MAKING A LOCAL
COALITION AIR BAKER TULARE
COUNTY NO WORKS PRIMARILY WITH.
FARMWORKERS APARTMENT
COMMUNITIES AND TODAY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MR
ABOUT THE SINGING. ON A ROBUST
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM PROGRAM
LATE INTO. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HELLO MY NUMBER SIXTY
THREE THAT IS LINE SIX THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
MARKETS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK A COALITION
THE STATE WAITING TO SPAIN OF
ON ORGANIC AGRICULTURE
ORGANIZATION MR DAHLE SEEMS A
PLAN THAT COMES AT A TIME OF
GREAT CHANGE FOR CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AS FARMERS STATE.
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES FROM
THE CORONAVIRUS AND BACK AND
GREATER WEATHER EXTREMES
INCLUDING RIGHT WILL HAVE TO
PRESSURES FROM A CHANGING
CLIMATE BUT HE'S CRISES CHOIR
INNOVATION INCLUDING NEW WAYS
TO ADDRESS CULTURAL MANAGEMENT.
TO REVIEW AND IMPROVE. THREE
TECHNOLOGICAL BALANCE HELLO
HEALTH WE FEEL THAT NELSON HAS
THE RIGHT PERSON MAKE THIS AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH I WITNESS. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBERS FIVE DEADLINE SIX
FIVE THE LINE IT'LL- THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE THIS IS LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL A CALLING TODAY
IN SUPPORT. OF BILLS ANY
FURTHER. POSITION OF THE
DEPARTMENT PESTICIDE
REGULATION- I THINK IT'S BEEN
SAID MULTIPLE TIMES- BUT DOES
BEAR REPEATING ABOUT HAS THE-
LONG. HISTORY WITH AGRICULTURE-
CLIMATE. CONSERVATION GROUPS
AND OTHERS- AND HAS ALWAYS
LOOKED TO STRIKE BALANCE- AND
IT'S BEEN FAIR MINDED AN OPEN-
WE THINK HE IS THE RIGHT PERSON
AT THE RIGHT TIME FOR THIS JOB-
AND WE WISH HIM ALL THE BEST-
IN THAT IN ON A PERSONAL NOTE.
MADAM PRO TEN HAVING WORKED
WITH BELL FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
ON A VARIETY OF ISSUES DEALING
WITH CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND OTHERS. I PER-
AND- TO BE TALKING WITH YOU
TODAY AND GIVE HIM FULL SUPPORT
NEGATIVE ABOUT OKAY DO YOU
AGREE JOB. WHICH DOESN'T MEAN
THAT IT'S GOING TO EASY. BUT HE-
WE FOUR. IN HIS ABILITY TO DO
THAT AND REALLY TAKE PRIDE IN
GIVING HIM A CONIRMATION AND
SUPPORT TODAY PLEASE VOTE I BY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
ARE WE HAVE ANOTHER PERSON WILL
BE JUST A MOMENT HERE WHAT WE
GET THEIR LINE NUMBER. I AM
JUST GONNA REMIND EVERYONE THAT
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR DAHLE SINI
YOU WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD AGAIN
THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO. IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT FOR NEXT A
QUESTION OR COMMENT THAT IS
LINE FIFTY SIX LINE FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT THE NEW
MODEM TURNED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENT DURING HER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COMPONENT
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN PART AT
DIRECTOR TOLD ME HIS CAREER AND
WITHOUT ALL HEARD OF THE
DEVOTED CLAVEL CULTURE AND YOU.
NEEDED TO LEARNING AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I AM
VERY MUCH OF HIS WORK. I TO
WORK THROUGH CHALLENGING
HEARING. SOLUTION ON THAT NEED
WE APPRECIATE. AND ALL OF THE
WORKING FOR HIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE WITNESSES
MADAME MODERATOR. I DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
PROCEED OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU IN
A MINUTE I OKAY HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
OPPOSITION. LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE I'LL JUST. LOOK
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEEING NO
ONE THERE I MET A MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU FOR
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- OF
DIRECTOR DAHLE SINI YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO- TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF DIRECTOR DAHLE
SINI. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU AT A
MODERATOR LET ME GO BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
SENATOR MINING HAS- ASKED TO
SPEAK THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR. I
WOULD JUST LIKE THE PRIVILEGE
OF MAKING- THE MOTION FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF DIRECTOR DOES
SINI AND I JUST WANNA OBSERVE.
AS WE'VE ALL RECOGNIZED THE-
OFTEN CROSS FIRE INTERESTS IN
POSITIONS AND EMOTIONS. CAUGHT
UP IN THE REGULATION OF
PESTICIDES IN THE SEARCH FOR
ALTERNATIVES THE SPECTRUM OF
SUPPORT MANIFEST IN THE
WITNESSES THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
TODAY- I THINK RULING
UNDERSCORES THAT. AT DIRECTOR
DOSING IS INDEED THE RIGHT
PERSON AND HAS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED THROUGH HIS LONG
CAREER ON RELATIONSHIPS
THROUGHOUT THE AG INDUSTRY WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
WITH THE ORGANIC COMMUNITY THE
I. P. M. COMMUNITY WHATEVER
THAT MIGHT BE- SO IT'S AN HONOR
TO. MOVE HIS. APPOINTMENT
NOMINATION FOR CONFIRMATION
HERE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
THANK YOU CENTER MINING THANK
YOU SO MUCH- I COMPLETELY AGREE
I MEAN THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN
ON THE RULES COMMITTEE FIRST
TOP. IT UP UP. YOU WHAT YOU
OVERSEE IT A SIMPLE SUBJECT
YEAH I MEAN IT IS COMPLEX. OF
THE ABILITY TO BRING DISPARATE
VOICES TOGETHER IS SOMETHING
THAT IS- IT'S AN ART FORM
FRANKLY AND- SO I'M THRILLED TO
HEAR THE TESTIMONY BUT UP MY
BOAT WILL VERY MUCH DEPEND ON
YOUR BREED OF DOG HI. I'M
KIDDING TO THE LEGAL EXPERTS
BUT GET THE AND BUT I DO WANT
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
WELL I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
PROVIDE FOR THE RECORD DOES IT
SENATOR THAT SHE IS A- POUND
PUPPY. SCUTTLED LAST REAL HELLO
THERE'S ALSO SOME PALM. IN
THEIR- SHE'S BEEN BEHIND FIFTY
SEVEN THAN A REAL HANDFUL.
WONDERFUL WELL THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT I WAS LATE BECAUSE
MY MIND WAS AT THE VET I WITH
AN EMERGENCY SITUATION BUT ALL
GOOD GOODBYE YOU WE HAVE TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF ENJOYMENT
IN THE DAY AND SO YOU JUST
PROVIDED BY- SENATOR MINING
MADE A MOTION MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES RIGHT IF AYE MINING AYE
MONNING AYE ROTH ALL RIGHT ROTH
AYE WILK. AYE ATKINS AYE AYE
CONCISE AYE GRADUATIONS
DIRECTOR THAT WAS UNANIMOUS
THANK YOU. NOT AND I KNOW THAT
WE JUST HAD A BREAK SO I'M
ASSUME AND- AS I LOOK AT OUR
STENOGRAPHER THAT WE'RE GOOD TO
KEEP GOING. AND DIRECT ARE YOU
ARE FREE TO LEAVE AND WE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ITEM D. N. E. AND THAT IS
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD. AND WE HAVE
MISTER OSCAR GONZALEZ JUNIOR
WITH US AND WINDY BOTH. THEY
WERE. BOB VIEW. AND I MR
GONZALEZ WILL START WITH YOU
LET YOU MAKE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS RECOGNIZE ANYBODY YOU
WOULD LIKE THAT IT IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO YOU
AND SUPPORTING YOU- THEN WILL
MOVE TO MISMATCH TO DO THE SAME
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO TALK TO BOTH
OF YOU AT THE SAME TIME. EIGHT
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WILL PUTTING. AYE
SOMETIMES WE CAN TAKE A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT. BOARD LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM YOU SO MISTER
GONZALEZ GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. I
AM PRO TEM MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR CONFIRMATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD.
I'M GRATEFUL THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND HIS STAFF FOR HAVING
THE CONFIDENCE IN ME TO ASSIST
WITH IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
MANY REFORMS AND POLICY CHANGES
THAT ARE NEEDED TO STRENGTHEN
THE HORSE RACING INDUSTRY.
TODAY MY WIFE FOCUSING CHOP
JOINS ME. WELL WE'VE BEEN OF WE
SHOULD RECENTLY CELEBRATED
FIFTEEN YEARS OF MARRIAGE AND
PARTNERSHIP THAT IS BUILT
AROUND HELPING LESS FORTUNATE
AND GIVING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY HELLO MY GRANDFATHER
HOMES HLL GONZALEZ WOULD ALSO A
JOIN ME IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE
CURRENT HEALTH CRISIS THAT HE
SPENT OVER FORTY YEARS AS A
BACKSTRETCH BURGER I CALIFORNIA
RACETRACKS TAKING CARE OF THE
RESOURCES FOR LIVING. BUT IT IS
FOOTSTEPS IN THE FOR OF ROUTE
TO. TAKE HER OF RESOURCES. AND
TODAY I'M FORTUNATE TO SERVE AS
VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
HORSE RACING BOARD. WHAT IS THE
BALANCE OF GOVERNMENT SERVICE
DESK KNOWLEDGE OF THE HORSE
RACING INDUSTRY. I CAN BE OTHER
DISTRICT. FORCES ARE MOST
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT ASSET. THE
CASE OF HORSE RACING IT'S THE
TRAINERS JOCKEYS FORM FOR ME
GROOMS HOT WALKERS EXERCISE
RIDERS NOT WATCHING
INTERNATIONAL CLERKS STARTING
GATE CREW CONCESSION WORKERS
PARKING LOT ATTENDANTS AND MANY
OTHERS. WHO MADE THE INDUSTRY
FUNCTION. IN ADDITION TO MAKING
SURE HORSES ARE SAFE. THIS
FEATURE THE NEED TO SAFEGUARD
THE WORKFORCE ACTORS DESCRIBE.
IF CONFIRMED TO CONTINUE MY
SERVICE ON THIS FEATURE BE I
WILL COMMIT TO THE FOLLOWING.
IT SURE THAT ALL PARTICIPANTS
AND STAKEHOLDERS ARE TREATED
FAIRLY. AND THAT TEIR VOICES
ARE HEARD. IMPLEMENT REFORM SO
THAT HORSES AT ALL LEVELS OF
COMPETITION ARE PROTECTED IN
STATE. YOU SURE THAT THE NEEDS
OF BACKSTRETCH WORKERS WHO ARE
MOSTLY IMMIGRANTS ARE RESPECTED
AND TREATED WITH DIGNITY. ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT FRONT SIDE
WORKERS MANY OF THEM UNIONIZE
HAVE AGREEMENTS AND CONTRACTS
WITH MANAGEMENT THAT WORKS FOR
ALL PARTIES. TRADERS SHOULD
ALSO HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
WHEN IT COMES IDENTIFY WAYS TO
MAKE OR TRACING SAY AND BIBLE.
OWNERS AND THEIR INVESTMENTS
NEED TO BE PROTECTED THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT SHOULD BE
APPLIED IN A FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER. FINALLY WE
NEED TO SEEK WAYS TO SUPPORT
SMALL FARMS AND RANCHES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA READ. CALIFORNIA
THOROUGHBRED BREEDERS MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S SECOND LARGEST
BREEDING STATE ONLY BE TACKY.
THIS STANDING. BECAUSE BREEDERS
JOBS AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
WORLD ECONOMIES AB CLOSING I
STAND BEFORE YOU AS A PRODUCT
OF THE HORSE RACING INDUSTRY
AND SOMEONE WHO SPENT YEARS
WORKING IN GOVERNMENT. THE
PUBLIC CAN COUNT ON ME TO ST IN
THE INDUSTRY SO THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS CAN ENJOY THIS FOR
EXPORT. IT SO THAT INDUSTRY
LEADERS AND THE PEOPLE WHO TAKE
CARE OF HORSES. WE HAVE AN
INDUSTRY THAT WILL ONCE AGAIN
BECOME A MODEL FOR THE REST OF
THE NATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MS MITCHELL
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND- I WANT TO
SAY IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
EVEN IF IT'S- BEFORE INDIA'S
YOU KNOW. I'M SAD TO NOT BE
THERE IN PERSON I MISS
SACRAMENTO. ANYWAY TO OPEN MY
SEEING. WHAT AN HONOR TO IT IS
TO BE CONSIDERED BY THE SENATE
CONFIRMATION. HEARING BUT I
WOULD I. WE WERE MISSING A VERY
IMPORTANT PERSON TODAY IS OUR
CHAIRMAN DR FERRARO HE IS WE'RE
TOLD RECENTLY IS THAT YOU KNOW
HAS CODED AND IS ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW HAS SYMPTOMS AND WE'RE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HIM WE
SEND HIM LOVE AND PRAYERS AND
THOUGHTS- FOR SPEEDY RECOVERY.
I AND I THINK THE SENATE FOR
THEIR FLEXIBILITY HIS
CONFIRMATION PROCESS. I ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
APPOINTING UNIVERSE REESING
BOARD AND HAVING FAITH IN MY
ABILITIES TO SERVE ON BOARD. AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS. MOSTLY
DOMINATED BY MEN I BELIEVE THAT
AND CONSIDERATION OF MY
APPOINTMENT AS MY LONG PERSON
GOVERNMENT IN ADDITION. WROTE
BACK. RESPECTIVAS TO BRING THE
IT FORWARD DURING THIS CRUCIAL
TIME IS DEFINITELY A DIFFERENT
BOARD- FROM THE ONE THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY. CONSTITUTED IT'S A
BOARD OF INCLUSION IT'S
IMPORTANT. OKAY CENTER FREE
PASSAGE QUESTIONS AND A BOARD
THAT'S PUSHING FOR REFORMS AND
MAKING THE TOUGH DECISIONS.
HAVING SERVED ON THE STATE
BOARD FOR ABOUT TEN MONTHS I
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH OSCAR
VISITING AT THE RACETRACKS
GETTING TO KNOW THE INDUSTRY
AND INTENDED TO UNDERSTAND THE
RAPAPORT DOESN'T THE REFORMS
THAT ARE NEEDED. I'M PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE THUS
FAR BUT I KNOW MORE IS THE- HIS
FIRST. AREAS INDUSTRY I'VE
PUBLIC IN AND ROB ROY
PERSPECTIVES. IN FACT WHEN
INDUSTRY PAPER SUGGESTED THAT
I'M CONSIDERED INCLUSIVE VOICE
OF REASON ON. GEN HELP TO
CONTINUE IN THAT VEIN DURING MY
SERVICE ON THIS FOR. HI I DON'T
HAVE ANYONE WITH ME TODAY IN MY
HOME OFFICE MY BOSTON TERRIER
PUPPIES IS OUTSIDE BECAUSE SHE
WAITING TO GET. MY SH BUT-
FRIENDS FAMILY WHO WERE
LISTENING IN ON THIS HEARING
OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE
COMMITTEES TIME TO NOT BE
TESTED BUT THEY ARE HERE AND-
YOU KNOW. SHE WORKED IN
PARTICULAR. AS YOU SINGLE MOM
AND I SURE TIME DIDN'T KNOW HOW
WAS GOING TO TURN OUT. OR IN
LOVE ME AND CAN THROUGH IT ALL
I AM HONORED EARLY IN MY CAREER
JUST SERVICES STAFF IN THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY AND I
REMEMBER MY MOM COMING TO. BE
IN. WHEN I WAS FOR ALL THE- AND
WHILE WE- CAP CAP SHE ACT EYED.
I'VE NEVER FORGOTTEN THAT
MOMENT AND I HOPE. HE I ALSO
WANTED THE STAFF THE AGING. THE
SENATE AND THE CRB FOR THE
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
CONFIRMATION PROJECT PROCESS.
AND COLLABORATING
COLLABORATIVELY BOARD ON EVERY.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR SCRATCHING
YOUR NEW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
REALIZING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED. TO HIRE A NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR IN THE BEGINNING OF MY
SERVICE ON THE BOARD I ASKED TO
BE PUT IN THE HIRING PROCESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS
INCLUSIVE. AND THOROUGH. SAY WE-
GREAT HIRING HE'S- THE RIGHT.
THE RIGHT TIME. I AM ALSO
WORKING WITH ALL THE CRB STAFF
WERE SUPPORTIVE AND HELPFUL AND
ALWAYS ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND
TRADING BOARDING PUBLIC WITH
PEOPLE RESPECT. I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE ALSO AND
SALAS WE WERE APPOINTED ON THE
SAME DAY AND WORST. FOR WE'VE
BEEN TO. AND CALLS AND HE
ALWAYS ME TO KEEP IN MIND AND
LIVELIHOODS OF THE BACKSTRETCH
WORKERS HE WORKS TIRELESSLY ON
THE WORD PUTTING HOURS SOLVE
DIFFICULT PROBLEMS HE'S A GREAT
FRIEND AND BOARD MEMBER AND I'M
PROUD. OF HIM. ALL THIS CLOSE
BY SAYING. TO THE SENATORS AND
THEIR STAFF. I KNOW IT'S NOT
EASY WORK ON A GOOD DAY. DURING
THIS TIME OF CODE EVERYONE IS
BEING ON. DRESS THE LIMIT. ALL
OF YOU ARE ALL THAT YOU DO IS
THE STATE HAPPY TO ANSWERING
QUESTION AND- THANK YOU MISS
MITCHELL LET ME START WITH YOU
SENATOR ROTH. REMEMBER TO.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM AND
MAKE IT EASY I HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NO QUESTIONS CONGRATULATIONS TO
BOTH OF YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD
THANK YOU CONFIRMATION. YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER VICE
CHAIR. OUR HAVE GOTTEN NOTHING
BUT RAVE REVIEWS- ABOUT- BOTH
YOU SO I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS EITHER. SIX EIGHT.
SHOULD I MAKE IT REALLY EASY
FOR THEM THE- I JUST
CONGRATULATE YOU ARE BOTH ON
YOUR APPOINTMENTS AS BOARD
MEMBERS AND ALL READING WHAT
HAS HAPPENED SINCE OUR LAST
DISCUSSION AND I THINK THAT WAS
EARLIER THIS YEAR ON THE
SITUATION IN THE FIRST. THREE
AND OUT OF THE- FEDERAL. THE
REFORM PLAN AND THE WINDOWS. IS
VERY VERY HOT INSPIRING. WE'VE
GOT THE RIGHT GROUP TO IN GOING
TO REALLY MAKE OUR- RACING
INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE AND SHE
SAID- MISS MITCHELL A- ON.
MARCH FOR THE NATION I BELIEVE
THAT ALSO A MISTER GONZALEZ
MADE THE SAME COMMEN BECAUSE
IT WAS SOMETHING VERY I THINK
WE'RE- ALL OF US SINCE SINCE.
YOU KNOW WE LOVE OURSELVES BUT
WHEN YOU ARE I AM. LOOKING
DEATH BUT WE'RE PARENTS WOULD
HANDED THIS CREDIBLE. THIRTEEN
THEN TRADITION IN OUR OWES OH
NO HAPPENED SO YOU YOU REALLY
TAKEN AT IT NEEDS. TO BE AND I
KNOW GOING FORWARD YOU'RE GOING
TO TAKE IT TO EVEN HIGHER
LEVELS SO YOU HAVE MY COMPLETE
SUPPORT AND- AGAIN ACTUALLY
ACTIONS ARE TIPPING AND- VERY
IMPORTANT SERVICE. TO THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SUPPORT
THANK YOU ALL OF. YOU WILL HAVE
MY BOAT. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES CENTER MINING. THANK YOU
WELL I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN
HOLDING THESE NOMINEES THESE
APPOINTEES AND I ESTEEM I DID
WANT TO ASK JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS THE SPEAKER TO
EDUCATE. ALL OF THE- ALSO DID
START BY. CONSIDERATION SENDING
HEALING THOUGHTS TO DR FERRARO-
I DID HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH HIM BY PHONE BUT IT
WAS TRUE THAT CONVERSATION.
FORMED THAT HE'D JUST BEEN
DIAGNOSED IS WITH COVERT
NINETEEN SO WE CUT THAT
CONVERSATION CLOSE I APPRECIATE
THE PRO TEM FOR FACILITATING.
HIS CONFIRMATION WITHOUT THE
NEED TO APPEAR IN WE'RE WISHING
HIM A FULL AND SPEEDY RECOVERY.
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH MR
GONZALEZ AND MISS MITCHELL-
WHAT A WONDERFUL MOST SAY CAN
DIVERSITY THEY BOTH BRING- WITH
MR GONZALEZ. EIGHT GROWING UP
BACKSTRETCH WORKER IN KNOWING
THE INDUSTRY INSIDE OUT IN
PARTICULAR FROM THE WORK FORCE
POINT OF VIEW. AND THEN MISS
MITCHELL COMING FRESH EYES ON
TO TRY TO HELP BRING A PUBLIC
VOICE MAY BE TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AND LINE UPS THAT IN
EVERYONE. IS THERE TURNS ABOUT
SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU.
BOTH TO ADDRESS SOME FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE THE PROGRESS BEING
MADE- WITH THE DEATHS OF RACING
HORSES AND HOW YOU. SEE THE
VOICES OF THOSE MANY WHO
ADVOCATE THIS IS A SPORT THAT
SHOULD NOT BE. LICENSOR K. IS
THERE AN ACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF
COURSE DEATHS- IN CALIFORNIA
HORSE RACING AND EITHER ONE OF
YOU COULD LEAD OFF ON THAT. I
COULD QUESTION SENATOR ALL
RIGHT I WANT TO FIRST SO THANK
THE SENATORS FOR THE HARD WORK
THAT WENT BEHIND SENATE BILL
FOUR SIX NINE AM CENTER DODGE
THANK YOU C. H. R. B. NEW POWER
WITH. DRESS IN AND FASHION
ANYWAY THE SENATE RACE TRACKS
THAT AREN'T READ MORE STANDARD
SO ONE THANK YOU RECENTLY TO
EXERCISE THOSE STORIES IT WOULD
LEAVE IT MAKES THE PROGRESS AT
THE TRACK. IN TERMS OF.
FINALITY IS ACCEPTABLE THIS
FEATURE BE HAS MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS IMPORTANT STRIDES
BUT WE HAVE MUCH MORE TO DO. I
FEEL THAT- DR- FOR OUR WOULD
WOULD ADEQUATELY STAGES ALL THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE ON ON
MEDICATION- LIMITING THE COURT
RECORD THEY'RE ALWAYS SO MAKING
SURE AT LEAST SIX IS NOT IS NO
LONGER FOR. YOUR OLD STARTED
EARLIER THIS YEAR. SO YOU
SHOULD HAVE A VERY WATCH OF
SMOKE OVER HORSES OF COURSE FOR
YOUR OLD. OLDER WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED TO COMPETE UNLESS THE
DO A- MORNING WORKOUT IT'S-
MERRY. WE ALSO BILL EMPOWER
OVER TRACKS TO BUILD OFF OF
RESTRICTIONS AROUND MANY. OF
THE VICTORIOUS INJECTIONS USED-
I BELIEVE OVER USED BOTH USE
THE NEEDLES AND HORSES OPENING
WILL BE ABOLISHED- BUT WE AT
LEAST HAVE IT SO THAT HE CANNOT
BE USE ON. THE ANKLE OF FORTY.
INSTEAD OF BEEN MADE AT THE
RACETRACKS LIKE SENATE ON HALF
A MILLION DOLLAR CAN ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THAT WILL CREATE HIGH
RESOLUTION DETECTION OF WELL
BOUNCE IN BRUISES AN IMPOSSIBLE
FRACTURES. FINALLY WE THINK
THAT THE POSTMORTEM ANY CROPS
USE UP COLLECTION THANK YOU FOR
THAT. THAT WERE WAITING ANY
FUTURE SITUATION. THAT TAKE
LIVES BUT I JUST WANT TO LET.
YOU KNOW THE THAT THAT THAT THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO
COMMISSIONER MITCHELL AND I AND
THE OTHERS THAT. RACING EASTER.
WE THAT WE HAVE ALLIES AND
PARTNERS NOT NOT ONLY ACROSS
INDUSTRY BUT ALSO MEMBERS WERE
ON THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU IN
A SAME QUESTION TO MISS
MITCHELL IF YOU WANT TO ADD ANY
THING TO THAT. SURE THANK YOU
QUESTION CENTER MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THE
OTHER DAY- CHAT PRIOR TO THIS.
YEAH IT JUST ADDING TO WHAT CAN
IS ALL BAD I. THE FIVE JUDGE
PANEL THAT THE GOVERNOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PANEL THAT LOOKS AT
HORSES BEFORE THEY RACE. JACK
PANEL. AS YOU THE PARSES THE
TRAINING. AND FLAGGED ANY
ISSUES I THINK THAT THAT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL TO TAKE
COURSES OUT RACES AND NOT LEAVE
IT TO THE DECISION OF THE
TRAINERS AND OWNERS I'M IN.
STRONG FOR AS WELL. BUT AS I
SAID WE NEED MORE REFORMS ARE
NEEDED WE'VE MADE- SOME
REGULATORY CHANGES AND THE
TRACKS AND IMPLEMENT THOSE EVEN.
RIGHT ACROSS. SO I THINK YOU
KNOW IT'S MORE IT'S ABOUT A
STATEMENT THAT'S COMING FROM
THE BOARD FROM THE COMMISSION
SO THAT EVERYONE KNOWS WHERE
THIS WHERE FOCUS. AND WE WILL.
CLEAR WE'RE WE'RE MOVING ACTION
AND EVERYONE'S AND SO WHAT IT'S
FAR FROM PERFECT WE'VE MADE
WE'VE MADE SOME PROGRESS. THANK
YOU BOTH AND THEN IF JUST A
FINAL QUESTION- AND IT CAME UP
IN OUR CONVERSATIONS AND WAS
MENTIONED BY MISS MITCHELL IN
HER OPENING- THIS IS BEEN A
PREDOMINATELY- A MALE DOMINATED.
IN INDUSTRY- SOME EXCEPTIONS
BUT IN INDUSTRY THAT'S PERHAPS
NOT BEEN. FRIENDLY TO MORE-
INTERESTED IN. GENDER DIVERSITY
WEATHER'S BACKSTRETCH WORKERS
JOCKEYS TRAINERS- THE WHOLE
SPECTRUM SO I'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM BOTH OF YOU JUST BRIEFLY-
AND HONESTLY QUITE WHAT ARE
SOME INITIATIVES THAT ARE
EITHER EXIST COULD COULD BE AN
IDIOT ON PARTNER FOUR EIGHT
YEAR OF. I'M YOUTH ORGANISER.
MIGHT AN AN AMADOR THAT SEEN
PRETTY CLOSED TWO YOUNG WOMEN
THROUGH THE YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING THAT. WELL
THE CRB IS LIMITED IN WHAT WE
COULD DO WE CAN'T SET A TONE
CANNOT PROVIDE LEADERSHIP.
THERE WAS A NONPROFIT GROUP
THAT. SO FINDING THAT KEEP YOU
FOR THE BOARD JUST NOT LONG AGO
AND- AFTER LOOKING AT THE BOARD
AND IT'S THE COMPOSITION ALMOST
ALL IN TURN MAPLES I. LET THEM
KNOW. THE BOARD HOWEVER WITH
THE CHIU. OF ACTUALLY POSITION
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM A CALL
FROM NINE TO ELEVEN. I WAS
REQUIRING THEM TO FEEL THOUGH.
THAT WITH WOMEN LEADERS. I
BELIEVE THAT THE INDUSTRIES ALL
THIS IS THE THIRD PERSON BE
QUITE HONEST WE HAVE A LONG
WAYS TO GO BACK WHEN I GREW UP
ON. THE PRESSURE MANY MANY MORE.
LEADERSHIP'S THAT ALL THE-
EXERCISE RIDERS TEND TO BE.
BLACK BELIEVES WITH. SOFTER
MORE J. CAN BE MUCH LIGHTER UP.
I BELIEVE MAKE EXCELLENT-
THANKS AN EXERCISE RIDER WE
ALSO NEED TO HAVE. TRAINERS AND
OWNERS. IN I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE TO REACH OUT. TO
ESPECIALLY THE. THE WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING HEALTH OF BOTH
OF COURSE FARMS AND PEOPLE
EMBRACE TRAILS OUT THERE ALSO
HAS TO BE YOU KNOW JUST USE
MORE CONVERSATIONS WHETHER IT'S
FORUMS ROUNDTABLES ARE SOME
EXPECT OF FROM THE BEGINNING I
EXPRESSED IT TO COMMISSIONER
MITCHELL THAT I WANTED TO WORK
WITH HER ON WELL I MEAN THESE
ARE I BELIEVE IT IS CRITICAL
AND WE DO HAVE ONE VACANCIES
YOU CAN TELL ON THIS BOARD AND
IN MY HOPE AND EXPECTATION IS
AT ITS FIELD. THE NEXT
COMMISSIONER IS A WOMAN. WHO
CAN JOIN US IN OUR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER MITCHELL
YEAH I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE
HAVE NO BETTER ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN IN THE INDUSTRY THAT
OSCAR REALLY HE'S BEEN AMAZING
AND BEEN- VOCAL ABOUT THIS
ABOUT SUPPORTING WOMEN IN THE
INDUSTRY I TALKED ABOUT THE WAR
THAT CAME BEFORE. I YEAH TALK
ABOUT SENATOR MINE ON THE
PHONE- EASILY SEE. STAFF IS
LIMITED BUT WE ARE DOING SOME
SORT OF INTERNSHIP PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE WOMEN TO GET INTO THE
INDUSTRY AND THEN TALKING TO
YOU YOU KNOW TRACKS AND
TRAINERS AND OWNERS WHEN THEIR
LICENSE CAN BE FOR US TO ENSURE
THAT YOU KNOW THEY ARE LOOKING
AT DIVERSITY AS WELL SO WE CAN
GOALS YOU KNOW FROM THE BULLY
PULPIT AT BUT ALSO WITH OUR
STAFF. I HAVE TO SAY THAT ON.
THE RECORDING WOULD THAT WORK
ON THE TEACHER YEAH AND THEY DO
A BANG UP JOB SELFISH. I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL GET ANOTHER
WOMAN. YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
ABOUT THE INDUSTRY PEOPLE
GETTING GETTING BEHIND THAT AND
WORK. I THINK. YOU SEE YOU KNOW
PREVIOUS FOR A CHARGE HAPPY
THAT- YOU BROUGHT THAT UP AND
HOPEFULLY THAT'S THE WAY THAT'S
A WRAP FOR. THANK YOU. YOU SOME
BIRTH IT WHEN I WILL. BOTH OF
YOU BERMAN. IMPRESSIVE OF
PUBLIC SERVICE- HERE IN THE
CAPITOL IN WASHINGTON IN THE
NONPROFIT ARENA. ON MANY FRONTS
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR CAREERS
OF DEDICATION AND SERVICE MADAM
PRO TEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THE- WE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK A QUESTION
OR TWO I DID HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET- DR FERRARO
IN DEL MAR AND TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT OF THE TRACK GIVE IT AFTER
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WERE
RAISED. MORE THAN A YEAR AGO.
AND THIS PROCESS. IS TO CUT
TRACK. OF COURSE ISN'T THE HEAD
FROM YOU KNOW WHERE THE START
AND GET ON TRACK BEFORE THE
RACE SEE THE- THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE. AND BRILLIANT WITH HIS
ARM. EIGHT YOU KNOW I ASK A LOT
OF FOLLOWS THE THIS AN
OPPORTUNE YOU PUBLIC HEARINGS
BUT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
THE LOOK AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE- OF THE-
COMMISSIONER. AGAIN UP BEFORE
SIXTY NINE SENATOR. AND THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE REFORMS ADOPTED
BY THE BOARD AS IT RELATES TO
THE RIDING CROP IN THE REVIEW
OF FORCES FITNESS BEFORE EACH
RACE ALL OF THOSE. THOSE ISSUES
IN THE CONTEXT OF- ARM. YOU
KNOW THIS INDUSTRY AND WHAT
WE'RE FACED WITH RIGHT NOW AND
THE CONCERNS WE HAVE ABOUT.
ABOUT THE DEATHS OF HORSES. NEW
YORK CALIFORNIA- KENTUCKY OF
COURSE FLORIDA WHERE DO WE RANK
I MEAN HOW DO YOU BALANCE. BUT
THE REGULATIONS AND REFORMS WE
ARE DOING IN CALIFORNIA WITH
WHAT OTHER STATES DO AND THE
IMPACT THAT COULD HAVE ON US-
ECONOMICALLY COURSE THEY WILL
CONTINUE. TO PARTICIPATE IN AND
HORSE RACING I'M JUST
INTERESTED IT'S ART YOU DEAL
WITH THIS I'M EVERY DAY. I'M IN.
SENATE INSIDE YOUR FACE SCREEN
MAYBE YOU CAN START THIS TIME
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO MR
GONZALEZ I'D APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTS. SURE I THINK. AS FAR
AS THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO THE
INDUSTRY- IN CALIFORNIA IS FAR
AHEAD OF THE REST OF STATESAS
FAR AS REFORM AND I BELIEVE YOU
KNOW SUPPOSE CALIFORNIA SO GOES
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY I THINK
CALIFORNIA IS IN BETTER SHAPE
REGARDLESS YOU SAFETY THAN
OTHERS- BUT THERE'S MORE THAT
BE. I DON'T THINK THAT ANY THE-
REFORM. WAIT NEGATIVE IMPACT
THE TRACKS TO DO RACES YEAR
FAMILIAR SURE EXACTLY- JUST
DELMAR AS AN INCREDIBLE
FACILITY THAT HAS AMAZING RACES
AND- AT WORST IS A AND PEOPLE
WANT TO RAISE. ARE REFORMS- YOU
KNOW ARE REALLY ON THE BACK AND
ON THE- AMOUNT AS- MEDICINE
THAT CAN BE INJECTED INTO
HORSES AND. AND YOU KNOW JUST
LOOKING AT THE HORSE'S TRAINING
RECORDS HIS CENTER IN ADVANCE
OF THEM BEING ABLE TO RACE SO I
MEAN OUR PARENTS ARE YOU KNOW
PROCESS YOU'D BE THE REGULATORY
PROCESS TAKES TIME- I BELIEVE
THAT YOU DON'T WANT EVERYONE.
RULES AND IS THE RULES ARE YEAH.
INSISTENTLY FOLLOWED THAT I
DON'T THINK IT WOULD NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE ECONOMICS OF THE
HORSERACING I BELIEVE THAT-
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE THE FIRST
REYES AND THEY WANT TO SEE OUR-
A- THE WHOLE PROCESS AND- YEAR
HOW THE VIRUSES ARE TREATED AND-
ADRIAN THE ANIMALS AND SO I
THINK IT ULTIMATELY BENEFITED
ANY ANY REFORM. IT IS TIME TO
BE IMPLEMENTED AND FOR PEOPLE
TO COME ON BOARD BUT ONCE
EVERYONE'S YOU KNOW THE RULES
ARE CONSISTENT EVERY. MR
GONZALEZ. MY OPINION ON ON THAT
SUBJECT OF BOILS DOWN TO
COMPETITION SINCE COMPETITION
HE QUALITY SOUND HORSES IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S A- COMPETITION
BETWEEN US AND OTHER STATES TO
KEEP TRAINERS AND OWNERS AND
JOCKEYS. IT ARE CALIFORNIA THE
WAY I BELIEVE WE SOME OF THE
BEST CLIMATE FOR RACING. WE
HAVE THE ARGOSY LEAST. WE HAVE
OF POLICY MAKERS AND REGULATORS
I BELIEVE THAT EXERCISE
FLEXIBILITY- WHEN NECESSARY BUT
STICK TO THE TO THE RULE OF LAW
CALIFORNIA. SOME IS SOMEBODY
WOULD JUST ENJOY IT COMES TO
THE PURSE STRUCTURE THAT IS THE
AMOUNT IS OF THE TO THE
COMPETITORS OF EACH RACE OTHER
STATES HAVE CASINOS AND SOLD NO
REVENUE TENDS TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT THAT THEY COMPETE FOR
SHIPPING OR CROSS COUNTRY THAT
EXPENSE ANYMORE BUT WE ARE
EXPERIENCED ENOUGH SONORA
MISTER. YOUR STATUS SO WE-
PERHAPS A EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT IF YOU WILL BUT
THAT CALIFORNIA IS. IT IS
BREEDERS PROGRAM I JUST
DISCUSSED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
HOW POOR READERS ARE. THREE THE
PLUS YOU KNOW. WILSHIRE OR ARE
ARE BORN EACH YEAR WITH EVERY
FULL YOU HAVE ECONOMIES FROM
VETERINARIANS TO FEED
CARETAKERS TAX EVERYTHING YOU
CAN IMAGINE SEE OUR LITTLE
MICRO ECONOMIES ARE BUILT
AROUND THE SMALL FARMS AND WHEN
YOU ADD IN YOU KNOW ONE OR TWO
WITH A BRAND NEW HORSES ACT
INCREASE BOTH. AND HELP CREATE
JOBS AND HELPS REVENUE. SB IN
OCTOBER WHEN WE ABLE THE NEW
RIDING CROP RULE OUT. IT IS
GOING TO BE THE DISTRICT THIS
ROLE- THAT WILL ONLY ALLOW
JOCKEYS TO USE IT IN A DOWNWARD
MOTION SIX TIMES MAXIMUM WITH
THE PAUSE IN BETWEEN. IT IS BY
FAR THE MOST RESTRICTIVE. OF
WAR IN WAR. THIS IS SOMETHING.
IS SOMETHING THAT THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE STATE. YOU US
STATES TO COME UP WITH THE
NATIONAL STANDARD BECAUSE THAT
DID NOT HAPPEN WE WENT AHEAD
AND WE IMPLEMENTED THIS VERY
STRICTER USE OF THE WRITING
SURE THE JOCKEYS THAT WE WILL
WILL TAKE VERY UP CLOSE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS. USING IN
JEOPARDY BUT I DOUBT VERY
SERIOUSLY ORGANIS E. INTO
LEADING BECAUSE WE'VE LED THE
WAY ON ON UNINITIALIZED RIDING
CROP SO I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE WAY BECAUSE
CALPERS. ARE CURRENTLY STASHED
AT. IS THE BEST. I THANK YOU
ANNA AND I'M SO OF REFER AND
IMPLEMENTATION I THINK IN TERMS
OF OUR LEGISLATION AND
PRESENTED. THEY GIVES YOU MORE
POWER AS THE BOARD- THE
QUESTION IS EXERCISING THAT
POWER AND WHERE THE BALANCE IS
TO PUSH. UP FOR IMPROVEMENTS OF
THAT LAND TOWARDS LESS DEATHS
OF HORSES I GUESS IF THE ONLY
AND THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION THAT CAN BE HAD
THERE- IN TERMS OF THE RACING
SURFACES FOR EXAMPLE LET ME
JUST TAKE SANTA ANITA. SHOULD
THAT SURFACE BE RIVER HOW DO
YOU I AND I WATCHED ALLOF THE
MONITORING THAT TEST AND THUS
AND SUCH I DON'T THE GENERAL
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS HOW MUCH
GOES INTO WHAT YOU OF HOW YOU
WAIT. TO DETERMINE THE SAFETY
OF A- DO YOU HAVE FOR. I
ORDERED. ACTUALLY WEIGH IN ON
THINGS LIKE WHETHER A SURFACE
SHOULD BE REPLACED OR NOT- THAT
MIGHT BE A QUICK SIMPLE
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW BUT
MISTER GONZALES YOU WANNA SEE
YOU YES WE HAVE. BEEN THAT WAY
AND- IT'S BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST- THE IN THE ATLAS ANALYST
DESCRIPTION REPORT THAT THERE'S
AN INTERVIEW CONDUCTED WHAT THE
DOCTOR PETERSON WHO- RANK IN
ORDER OF SEQUENCE THAT SIR AT
THE TOP TOUR. AND. EVERYTHING
IS ON THE TABLE- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE RACE TRACKS ARE TAKEN.
OUT IS SUB MATTER VERY
SERIOUSLY WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPER INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE. THE FACT IS THE CLOTHES
ON THE LAST FUTURE MEETING
WANTED TO- INSTITUTE. A MONTHLY
CONVERSE MONKS THE RACETRACK
SUPERINTEND OF AND OTHER OF A
RACE TRACK IN TENNESSEE
TRAINING FACILITIES DISCUSS
BEST PRACTICES. OF DIFFERENT
USES OF SOIL OF. IN ONE
SERVICED ANOTHER ALSO SHARE IT
ABOUT THE CITY QUITMAN WATER
TRUCKS TO TRACTORS I JUST
BELIEVE THAT IS A VERY
PROFESSIONAL LIVES INDUSTRY IT
IS CRITICAL THAT BECAUSE HORSES
ARE SO DELICATE. WHAT THE RUN
ON. WE PROTECT AND WHEN YOU ADD
IN A DRY WEATHER WET WEATHER
SOMETIMES WITHIN A MONTH'S TIME
THAT CAN. DISRUPT THAT THIS
SERVICE SO I BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S A LOT MORE CHANGE THAT
NEEDS TO BE PAID BUT YES SHOULD
THERE BE THE OF. THE USE OF THE
COURT WITHIN THE CRB- TO.
MANDATE THAT RETRACT CHANGE
YOUR SURPLUS AB. THAT'S THE
WITHIN OUR AUTHORITY. LET IT
BEFORE MS MITCHELL RESPONSE LET
ME JUST ASK DO YOU BELIEVE YOU
HAVE THE AUTHORITY YOU NEED ART
RIGHT NOW ABLE TO MAKE SOME
PRETTY SERIOUS CALLS SHOULD YOU
NEED TO OR IS THERE ANYTHING
ELSE YOU WOULD NEED OF US TO BE
ABLE TO- TO DO THAT AND- SORRY
I JUST THOUGHT PROJECT THAT.
YOU HAVE WELL AS YOU DO THAT
IBM. THING ELSE. IN A WORD YES
OKAY STUDY UP ON THIS AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE DO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY WE NEED ONE COMES TO.
THE SERVICE OKAY. MISS MITCHELL
I'M I'M JUST I AM A FAN OF THE
SYNTHETIC OF TRACKS I THINK
THAT IS THE DIRECTION THATWE
NEED TO SERIOUSLY LOOK AT AND
BE HONEST SINCE I'VE BEEN ON
THE BOARD WE HAVEN'T REALLY
TAKEN A SERIOUS LOOK PREVIOUS
OR- AND HE- DID. SYNTHETIC
TRACKS AND THERE WERE MIXED
RESULTS AND SO EVERYONE POINTS
TO THAT IS THIS ISN'T THE
ANSWER. BUT I THINK THERE'S NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND NOT SUBSIDIARIES
DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS TO BE
HAD. AS FAR AS THE WORDINGI'M
NOT EXACTLY SURE WINNER
RESTORING USE WITH REGARD TO
MANDATE IN THE TRACKS THAT. IN
GIVING THEM THEIR LICENSE WE
SAY THAT YOU KNOW. HAVE A
SYNTHETIC TRACK. HAVING SAID
THAT HERE ARE FOUR SIX UNITED
DODD BILL ALLOWS US TO CLOSE
DOWN TRACKS IF THERE IS AN
EXCESSIVE NUMBER OF COURSE YES.
WE AREEXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
RECENTLY CALLED AN EMERGENCY
MEETING OF THE BOARD UNDER THAT
NEW LEGISLATION- BECAUSE OF THE
DEFICITS LOS ALAMEDA WAS AND-
ICE. AT THE HEARING AND SAID I
WAS DISAPPOINTED THAT WAS
OBVIOUSLY NOT. YOU KNOW EIGHTY
STRONGER. SIXTY PRISON IT WAS
MORE OF REASON FROM OUR LAWYERS
AND FACT I WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO
VOTED- THAT THE TAX SHOULD BE
SHUT DOWN IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
PLAY. IN SOME SAFETY PROTOCOLS-
I WAS I LOST THAT VOTE. WILL
END UP HAPPENING WAS THEY WENT
BACK AND DID AND- I TEND TO
COME UP WITH THE STATE PROTOCOL.
AND WE- ASK THE BORDER
SUPPORTED THAT LATER AND- THUS
FAR YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
WAITING TO SEE OVERALL HAVE
THAT'S THAT'S WORKING. AND AS
IT WOULD NICE TALK TO CENTER
MONNING LAST WEEK I SAID YOU
KNOW A LOT OF OUR OUR ROLE IN
OUR ABILITY IS SHE TO. SUPPORT
THE TRACK OWNERSHIP TO SAY
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT THIS SO
THAT THEY CAN THANK CRAP ON
TRAINERS AND- ON THEIR TRACKING
ORDER TO ENSURE HER SAFETY SO
WE'VE BEEN CLEAR THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO US FOR SAFETY I
THINK HAVING THAT HEARING ALSO
NEED US WAS. SAID SHE EVERYONE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO THIS IS YOU.
EXCESSIVE FORCE YES WE GOING TO
HOLD THESE EMERGENCY MEETINGS
HOLD YOUR FEET TO THE FIRE AND
EXPECTS CHANGE. Q. THANK YOU
FOR THAT ANSWER I WOULD JUST
SAY ARE YOU GIVEN I HAVE DEL
MAR IN MY DISTRICT I PAY VERY
CLOSE ATTENTION. LIKE MOST
PEOPLE I LOVE HORSE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED SO MR GONZALEZ THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- FOR ADVOCATES I'M
ON BEHALF OF. EVERYONE AND
EVERY PART OF WHAT MAKES OUR-
WERE FACING WORK PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO WORK THE HARDEST AND
PROBABLY. PAID THE ELITE. I OF
YOU TO EXERT YOUR FULL
AUTHORITY BECAUSE I THANK YOU
MORE THAN ANYBODY KNOW YOUR
CHARGE YOUR RESPONSIBILITY IN
THE FACT THAT IF IT IS NOT
BALANCED APPROPRIATELY WE WILL
LOSE SINGING CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
DO NOT SEE. L. HORSE. THEY DO
NOT WANT TO SEE WORKERS WHO ARE
NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECT IT AND
TAKING CARE OF WHETHER IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC OR JUST
GENERALLY SO I APPLAUD YOU BOTH
AND URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO BE.
ACTIVES FORWARD MS MITCHELL AS
I KNOW YOU ARE. I KNOW YOU
PERSONALLY- WHICH IS WHY I SAY
THAT. BUT I JUST THINK WE IF WE
DON'T DO IT APPROPRIATELY WE
STAND TO LOSE EVERYTHING- AND
IF IT COMES DOWN TO LOSING
EVERYTHING- PROTECTING CORPSES.
I THINK THE PUBLIC IS GOING TO
ERR ON THE SIDE OF PROTECTING
HORSES NO MATTER HOW MUCH. WE
ENJOYED DEL MAR ARE LOS ALAMEDA
SERVER I ANY ANY. OF THE ROAD
OF THE TRACKS SO I PLEDGE TO
YOUR HARD WORK YOU CLEARLY
DON'T GET PAID ENOUGH BUT- THE-
UP RESPONSIBILITY AND LOVE. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY I AM WE WILL NOW
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
I'M GOING TO START. WITH US
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE OF
PLEASE- WELCOME BACK THIS. THE
MEMBERS THE LAST LAST TIME
TODAY I PROMISE. YOU MIGHT
APPRECIATE THIS MADAM CHAIR THE
FIRST TIME I MET WENDY AND HAVE
WORKED WITH HER HAND ENJOY THAT
FRIENDSHIP AND WORKING
RELATIONSHIP- IN HER ROLES IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE IN
OTHER PLACES. FROM YOUR THE
DAYS OF YOUR PREDECESSOR'S
PREDECESSOR WENDY OPERA WAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY IN HER FIRST TERM.
AND I KNOW WENDY TO BE A
THOUGHTFUL IN HER DECISION
MAKING TO BE VERY HARD WORKING-
AND VERY INTELLIGENT AND I KNOW
THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE TO DO AN
EXCELLENT JOB ON THE C. H. R.
B. AND SO I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR HER CONFIRMATION THINKING
ABOUT APPROACH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOT SEEING ANYONE ELSE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
BEFORE I TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE LET ME REMIND
WITNESSES WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364
THE CODE IS. EIGHT ZERO FOUR
FIVE THREE FIVE SIX. IT'S ON
THE SCREEN AND TO LET ME TAKE A
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE
IF ANYONE IS THERE. SEEING NO
ONE- MADAME MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU FOR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I VIA
TELECONFERENCE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
MR GONZALEZ AND MISS MITCHELL
YOU WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF MR GONZALEZ AND MISS
MITCHELL PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD WILL GO
TO NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT. NINE SIX
EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS RENEE BAYARDO WITH
AT THE ARE YOU THE CALIFORNIA.
BY COLIN IN SUPPORT OF OSCAR
GONZALEZ. WE HAD A GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM
WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
ALWAYS REMEMBERS THE WORKERS.
WE ALSO TRUST THAT HE'LL DO THE
RIGHT THING IN THE SURE THAT I
CAN A FEW. SO WE ARE THAT YOU
ARE A BIG THING YOU. THIRTY ONE
THREE ZERO. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS OSCAR THE LOTTERY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I STARTED WORKING WITH
THE BACKSTRETCH WORKERS AT
SANTA ANITA RACETRACK TO
PROTECT THEIR WHAT BASE OF
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION THAT I'M
FOR A BAN ON HORSE RACING WITH
NO REGARD FOR THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THAT BAND WORKERS AND THEIR-
ACTUALLY. WHAT A POOR. PLATE
NUMBER. AFTER THIS REASON I'M
CALLING SUPPORT THE REAR. OF
CRT MEMBERS ARE GONZALEZ WENDY
MITCHELL AND GREG REFERRAL FEES
PUBLIC SERVANTS DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
UNPRECEDENTED REFORMS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE NOW HAVE
BEEN ORCHESTRATING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA IS NOW MODEL FOR THE
NATION OR STATE AND ALL THE
APPOINTEES SHOWN ON COMPROMISED
LEADERSHIP AT ALL. ANGELA
COUNTY. HORSE RACING AND ALSO
PRIORITIZED FIFTY FOR BOTH
HORSES AND WORKERS IN THIS
INDUSTRY THE REAPPOINTMENT OF
FUTURE OF THE MEMBERS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AFTER OR WILL SEND
THE MESSAGE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE REASON
ROOF. EFFORTS INCARCERATION AND
THAT THE PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE
WILL BE SUSTAINED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS WITNESS. SIXTEEN NINE ONE
SIX GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICAL TERM AND
SENATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS
IS LARRY SCHWARTZ ONE OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AUTHORITY OF RACING.
ARE MOST COMMONLY KNOWN AS KIND
OF CURRICULA JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY REPRESENTING THIRTEEN
CARE HOMES INVESTMENT
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY TO BOTH LIBRARIES.
WHEN YOU DRINK THE- WELL UNDER
TO DO BOTH YOUR ARE HAMID YOU
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD BUTTERY APPOINT. MY
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF SERVICE
UNITED STATES ARMY. TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF THE RAISING FARES WHAT
THE MOST CHALLENGING FORCE MOST
POSITIVE FORCE THE PEOPLE
YOU'RE WORKING WITH. THE
CASHIER REYES. AS WELL AS ANY
ORGANIZATION IS TO WORK AS A
TEAM. WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. YOU HAVE EVER
WANTED JESUS MORE. INITIALLY
GONZALEZ WITH MITCHELL AND MADE
IT A PRIORITY TO INVOLVE ALL
PARTY LOCATION CHEN ITEMS.
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IS THE
POSITION ARE ALL HERD IMMUNITY
BACK FROM THEIR POSITIONS. A
LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT. ALL
STAKEHOLDERS DON'T ALL AGREE.
PRESIDENT JOHNSON MITCHELL SB
PROVIDED LEADERSHIP AND
MOTIVATION MOTIVATION YOUR
AVAILABLE ANYTHING UNNECESSARY
MEDICATIONS SAFETY THE JOCKEYS
AND HORSES. THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
PUT CALIFORNIA IN THE FOREFRONT
OF THE LEADING MEDICAL A
POSITIVE CHANGE FROM AMERICAN
HORSE RACING INDUSTRY. MYSTERY
HELLO. USE MICHIGAN'S MITCHELL
ON THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHAT. I NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
THAT'S LINE SIX NOT GOING. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M PRO TEM AND
SENATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SUSPECT PARTLY CEO THE SNOWMAN
COUNTY FAIR AND WINE COUNTRY
RACING. AND I AM SPEAKING TODAY
TO GET MY VERY STRONG SUPPORT
TO COMMISSIONER GONZALEZ AND
MITCHELL. THAT THEY'VE BEEN ON
THE BOARD IT'S BEEN A BREATH OF
FRESH AIR THEY HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD TO BRING THEM. TOGETHER
UNDERSTAND. WHAT OF FAIR WORST
RACING VERSUS OUR OTHER TRACKS
THAT ARE- ROTORS ACROSS YOU
BROUGHT WAY AND I HAVE TO SAY
THAT- WITHOUT MR GONZALEZ IS
THE FIRST TIME IN FIVE YEARS.
THAT ANY COMMISSIONER SHOUT BE
PERSONALLY TO ASK MY OPINION
AND TO SUPPORT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IN. A RACING STYLE
THANK YOU I WANTED. THOSE TWO
INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU MISS
BURTON THANK YOU IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE NEXT PLEASE.
WHAT MY NUMBER SIXTY SIX THAT'S
LINE SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER THAT MIKE MONOGRAM WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE HI
CREATES COUNCIL. HELP RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION OF OPTICAL WORKERS
AS WELL AS THE STRONACH GROUP.
THE INDUSTRY HAS CHALLENGES BUT
WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF MISTER
GONZALEZ IMAGE VIGIL. THE HORSE
RACING BOARD IS IN GOOD HANDS
THEREFORE THE INDUSTRY IS IN
GOOD HANDS AND WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THEIR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. FOUR SEVEN.
SEVEN ZERO GO AHEAD. WE'RE
GONNA TRY LINE SEVENTY ONE LINE
SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS RINA
JAMARI BOARD MEMBER AT THE
CALIFORNIA EXCLUSION A STATE
FAIR I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER MY
STRONG SUPPORT PERMITS WELL
I'VE KNOWN WHEN HE SPOKE WITH
FRESH PLAN PERSONALLY FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND NOW WILL
NEED BOTH. OBJECTIVE AND
THOUGHTFUL AND I AM CONFIDENT
THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE TO DO A
GREAT JOB ON THE V. EIGHT.
THANK YOU. YOU NEXT MOVE NEXT
WITNESS. WE'RE GOING ONLINE.
SEVENTY TWO NINE SEVEN TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS ROSA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
THOROUGHBRED. RAINER'S IT WERE
IN SUPPORT OF MR GONZALEZ AND
MS WHICH SHOULD MISS MITCHELL
THEIR APPOINTMENTS TO THE STATE
CAN INDUSTRY WILL ACHIEVE THE
DIFFICULT. AND NEEDED GOALS OF
CHANGING IN OUR INDUSTRY WHILE
THERE CALIFORNIA THOROUGHBRED
TRAINERS MAY NOT ALWAYS AGREE
WITH YOU IMPORTANT TO YOU WE
KNOW THAT OUR PERSPECTIVES ARE
ALWAYS HEARD AND THEIR BELIEFS
INTO CONSIDERATION. AND OTHERS-
I'M- AND- RIGHT BEHALF OF THE
URBAN TREE WE ABSENT COMMITTEE
TO A THEIR APPOINTMENTS THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU NEXT TO AS A
REMINDER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF MR
GONZALEZ AND MISS MITCHELL YOU
WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WHITE THE
THAT. ZERO THANK YOU MADAM
APPROACH HIM HIM AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS LOUIS
BROWN CALLING TODAY INTO PORT
COMMISSIONERS GONZALEZ MITCHELL
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
FAIR THE CEO DRUM THAT. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND WE ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WITNESS. I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN A MOMENT. WE WILL
NOW MOVE BY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WANTED THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. BEING NO ONE HERE
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE LET'S
TAKE A LOOK ROOM ONE TWELVE.
OKAY I. WE'RE COMING BACK TO
YOU FOR WITNESSES VIA
TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
FOR MR GONZALEZ AND MISS
MITCHELL YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
AND AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION YOU
WILL PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
OKAY EIGHT MATAMATA WRITER I
THINK THIS IS THE LAST MOMENT
WE'LL TALK WITH YOU SO YOU WERE
INCREDIBLY WONDERFUL TODAY
THANK YOU. WELCOME IT- SAID
MADAM SECRETARY ARE I'M GONNA
AT LET ME JUST MAKE SURE DO WE
NEED TO SPLIT THE VOTE OR WE
CAN DO WE CAN MAKE A MOTION FOR
BOTH AT THE SAME TIME. YEAH
SOUNDS GOOD. MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT I MINE AYE MONNING
AYE ROTH ROTH I WILL CRY LOOK
AYE ATKINS HI I CAN SORRY IT
WILL THIS YEAR IT IS UNANIMOUS
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH
FOR ONE PATIENT. DIED AND PAIN
IN THE. CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU SENATORS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO- I WILL
JUST REMIND FOLKS THAT- GREGORY
FERRARO DR FOR A WILL BE PART
OF ITEM NUMBER TWO. THERE WERE
A COUPLE COMMENTS ABOUT HIM
DURING THE TESTIMONY AND US
CERTAINLY FROM ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT BUT RIGHT
NOW LET'S SEE I'M GOING TO ASK
MADAMS. OPEN ROLL ON I ONE. I
AM ONE ONE EIGHT- I APOLOGIZE
ONE A ITEM ONE A. ATKINS FIVE
ATKINS FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE
TWO ZERO YOU UNANIMOUS OP WITH
CONGRATULATIONS TO DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- AND THEN
AGAIN AT THANK YOU TO THE VICE
CHAIRMAN FOR CARRYING OUT
THROUGH THAT. TESTIMONY THE- I
THINK DOLLAR BILLS OKAY SO IT
IS FOR IT IS FOR IS IT OKAY.
SORRY SKINNER MINE THANK YOU-
MADAM SECRETARY THANK YOU SO
IT'S FOUR ZERO US STEEL OF THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. ITEM
ONE B. CAMBERLEY KIRCH MEYER
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
THAT IS UNANIMOUS. WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH ITEM C. D. N. A.
SO ON ITEM TO NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEMS TO F. THROUGH X.
LET ME SEE DO I NEED TO PULL
ANY OF THESE APPOINTMENTS OUT
FOR SEPARATE VOTE. I MY- I YEAH
OKAY I EN EL AND R. SO WE WILL
TAKE ITEMS TO F. G. H. J. K. L.
M. N. O. P. Q. R. S. T. U. V.
W. X. THAT IS THE MOTION DO I
HAVE THE MOST. THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING SAID THAT IT IS
I DIDN'T ALL OF THOSE ARE I
MENTIONED MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. BATES FIVE EIGHT FIVE
MONNING NIGHT MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK RIGHT I ATKINS HI
CONFI FIVE ZERO THANK YOU FIVE
ZERO ARE THOSE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED LET ME ASK FOR A
MOTION ON ITEM TWO I AND TO.
THANK YOU SENATOR BUNNING NO I
WOULD LIKE THOSE FURTHER SPLIT
OKAY ALL RIGHT LET ME- BUT A
HUNDRED LET ME ASK IF YOU WILL
MAKE THE MOTION FOR TO BUY
MOVED THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHT
IT'S NOT VOTING MONNING NIGHT
MORNING I ROTH AYE ROTH I WILL
CRY WILK AYE ATKINS HI I CAN
SORRY THAT IS FOUR ZERO WITH MS
IT'S NOT BEING THAT IS
CONFIRMED A MOTION ON TO L.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH R. MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. IT'S NOT BORING MONNING
HI MY NAME AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE
WILK. WILL NOT A VOTING ATKINS
HI I CAN SAY THREE ZERO THREE
ZERO- WITH TO NOT VOTING SO
THAT- CONFIRMATION IS ALSO
APPROVED THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY ASSERT OTHER BUSINESS
BEFORE WE GO TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION. THANK YOU MAKING SURE
YOU KEEP ME ON TRACK WITH THAT
WE WILL ARE ADJOURNED INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION.